Hallo, ich bin auch wieder da.
Relativ, ja, ja, ich wollte es gerade sagen, relativ oft bin ich da.
Aber ich sage euch Leute, heute war echt kein sonderlich toller Tag.
Du bist endlich als Software-Hardware-Ingenieur angestellt.
Was macht man denn als, also das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal nice,
aber was macht man denn als Software-Hardware-Ingenieur?
Also Software-Ingenieur kann ich mir vorstellen, Hardware-Ingenieur kann ich mir vorstellen.
Aber was macht denn ein Software-Hardware-Ingenieur? Der macht alles.
Alles in einem.
Warte mal, ich muss glaube ich meine Lautstärke richtig einstellen.
Ja, ja, ich hatte ja auch kein Teams offen.
Alles from scratch, ja.
Erstmal enjoyen, dann enjoye mal.
Low-Level-Full-Stack, also quasi so ein STM32, ESP32-Full-Stack.
Ach so, okay.
Ah.
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich, was du meinst.
Du kümmerst dich um die Software für irgendwelche Microcontroller-Geschichten
oder beispielsweise für irgendwelche Industriesteuerungen oder für irgendwas im Auto oder sowas in der Richtung.
Echt jetzt?
Nee, das kann nicht sein.
Im Dezember muss ich doch mehr gestreamt haben.
Na gut, im Dezember habe ich viel gemacht.
Im Dezember habe ich auch, habe ich hier immer richtig, richtig viel aufgeräumt.
Ich habe wieder MMO-Kreisel-Grind gemacht.
Und alles mögliche.
Steuerungskräte.
Steuerungskräte für E-Autos, okay.
Ich glaube dir, dass du weißt, dass generell wissen es die Zuschauer wahrscheinlich besser als ich selbst.
Leute, ich muss euch was erzählen.
Und zwar...
Ach Quatsch, ich bin im falschen Browser.
Wir haben doch im letzten Stream...
Nee, das stimmt gar nicht.
Im vorletzten Stream...
Ja, ja, Max, ist gut.
Wir haben doch im vorletzten Stream uns doch mit dieser Emulator-Kiste...
...hier beschäftigt, ja?
Ihr, ihr erinnert euch.
Ich habe jetzt noch ein bisschen rumgebastelt.
Und soll ich euch was sagen?
Oder was heißt?
Was heißt soll ich euch was sagen?
Ich kann es euch sogar zeigen, wenn ihr wollt.
Da muss ich aber erst mal anschließen wie dafür, weil ich habe die Kiste vorher abgemacht.
Ich kann es euch mal zeigen.
Ihr werdet, ihr werdet, ihr werdet staunen, werdet ihr.
Staunen.
Ähm, ich schließe die Kiste mal kurz an.
Ihr werdet staunen.
Ihr werdet poggerieren.
Ähm, ich hoffe ich schmeiße jetzt nichts runter.
Weil ich brauche da Stromkabel.
Stromkabel brauche ich.
Aha, Stromkabel.
Netzwerkkabel.
Oh, fuck.
HDMI-Kabel.
Ich habe es leider abgestöpselt alles wieder.
Netzwerkkabel.
Wo ist das HDMI-Kabel?
Ich zeige, ich zeige es euch.
Zeigen ist besser als, oder wie, zeigen ist besser als tausend Worte oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich zeige es euch.
Ihr werdet, ihr werdet poggen.
Oh, Capture-Karte dran.
Hätte ich mir selbst nicht gedacht, dass das so gut funktioniert.
Capture-Karte dran und jetzt den Xbox-Controller dran.
Und ich glaube dann ist gut.
So, jetzt kann ich einschalten.
Activate.
Alles klar.
Achtung, passt mal auf, Leute.
Elgato.
Elgato-Stell.
Die aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht funktioniert.
Ah, jetzt.
Okay.
Wow, wow, wow, viel zu laut.
Passt mal auf, passt mal auf.
Ihr werdet, ihr werdet poggen.
Ah, No Signal.
Nice.
Also erstmal, Xbox funktioniert.
Xbox Funktion, Xbox-Emulation funktioniert.
Leider nicht upscaled, nur normal.
Ich habe jetzt ein richtig, ich habe jetzt ein richtig schönes, ähm, Übersichtsmenü, ja.
Wenn du hier zum Beispiel ein Super Nintendo aufmachst, kriegst du sogar Video-Vorschau von manchen Super Nintendo Games, die in der Collection sind.
N64 kriegst du Vorschau, Vorschau von der Collection.
Und jetzt kommt's, jetzt kommt's, aber haltet euch mal fest.
Na?
Das, das war's.
Das, das Switch und PS3 läuft, hä?
Und, und Switch.
Und Switch, passt mal auf.
Ihr hört, glaube ich, den Sound.
Ich höre, ich höre den Sound jetzt nicht.
Ich hoffe, es ist nicht zu.
Ja, die Ladezeiten sind mit dem Walken-Treiber ein bisschen, bisschen, äh, im Arsch.
Die Ladezeiten sind definitiv schlechter als auf der echten Switch.
Das ist Bartoszera.
Bartoszera.
Aber der Switch-Emulator.
Den muss man zusätzlich, äh, äh, zusätzlich installieren.
Ja.
Ich besitze übrigens das Switch und ich besitze auch Links Awakening.
Ich besaß das sogar schon auf dem, ne, nicht Wink Wink.
Wirklich.
Ernsthaft.
No, no kappa.
Ich hab das sogar schon auf dem Game Boy.
Auf dem Game Boy war das.
Ich hatte es sogar auf dem Game Boy und dem Game Boy Color.
Okay.
Achtung.
Jetzt passt mal auf, wie gut das läuft.
Okay, es ist auf Französisch.
Weil ich noch nicht gecheckt hab, wie man die...
Wie man die, äh, Sprache umstellt.
Aber es ist jetzt erstmal egal.
Commencer.
Passt mal auf.
Seht ihr, wie gut und flüssig das läuft?
Am Anfang ruckelt es ein bisschen wie auf der Original-Switch.
Das läuft besser als auf der Original-Switch, Leute.
Das sieht besser aus und läuft besser als auf der Switch.
Okay, hat ein paar Grafikfehler.
Ja, dem, dem Kettenhund fehlt der Kopf.
Ich spiele es gerade mit dem Xbox 360 Controller.
Also extremst nice, oder?
Ich, leider, leider hat der Switch-Emulator keinen, keine Performance-Overlays.
Sonst, sonst könnte ich es euch zeigen.
Also andere Games haben Performance-Overlays.
Der hier leider nicht.
Aber was auch, was auch mega ist, was auch mega ist.
Guckt mal, Gamecube.
DoubleDash.
Ihr habt Hintergrundmusik.
Naja.
Ihr habt Hintergrundmusik und Ingame-Musik.
Hintergrundmusik, glaube ich.
Ja, ich mach die, ich mach die Hintergrundmusik.
Ich, ich hab, ich hab selbst keine.
Moment, ich muss das mal so einstellen, dass ich selbst was höre.
Äh, guckt mal, guckt euch das mal an.
Ich hab hier unten jetzt die, die Performance, die, die Performance-Overlay-Geschichten aktiviert.
Und das ist jetzt DoubleDash in 1080p.
Guckt mal, wie gut das, guckt mal, guckt mal, wie gut das aussieht.
Passt mal auf.
Guckt mal, wie gut das aussieht.
Äh, ByteDash.
Beide, beide Emulatoren.
Das, wo die Spiele besser unterstützt werden.
Das sieht, das sieht besser aus als, als ein Switch-Game.
Da kann man nix sagen, oder?
Also, das ist ein fucking Gamecube-Spiel.
Das sieht mega aus für ein Gamecube-Spiel, oder?
Und guckt euch mal die Performance an.
Guckt euch mal die Performance an.
Ex, extrem porges.
Ihr seht's unten links, das, das hat konstante, konstante 60 FPS.
Ja, und, und es hat, es ist, belastet im Endeffekt.
Nichts aus.
Ich könnte sogar noch, ich könnte sogar, also bei, bei, bei der Auslastung,
könnte ich theoretisch sogar noch, noch ein bisschen mehr einschalten.
Ich könnte sogar noch hierher gehen und sagen, ja, ähm, wir machen jetzt nicht nur,
wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt, wir rennen jetzt in 1044p.
Und machen sogar noch, keine Ahnung, hier, äh, Text, Texture-Filtering und, und Anti-Aliasing an.
So.
Ja.
Okay, da gehen wir mal runter auf 1080p mehr.
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt...
Läuft, bin ich mal gespannt.
Also, das sollte es eigentlich jetzt nicht mehr, nicht mehr packen.
1440p und...
Aber mal gucken, mal gucken.
Ich bin, ich bin gespannt.
Das Letzte, was wir rausprobieren.
Eigentlich wollte ich heute, wollte ich heute kein Gaming-Zeug machen.
Aber, äh, ich mein, das ist, guck mal, wie gut das aussieht.
Das ist ein Gamecube-Spiel, man.
Da kann man sich echt, da kann man aber gar nix sagen, oder?
Okay, jetzt packt's die 60 FPS nur noch, nur noch mit kleinen Slowdowns.
Ich merk schon, es, es, es dippt, es dippt zwischendurch ein bisschen.
Aber, hey, ich mein, guckt euch das mal ins, guckt euch das mal in Pause an.
Das ist...
Guck mal, das hält sogar die 60 FPS mit 1440p Anti-Elasing und Texturfilterung.
Das sieht besser aus, wie die meisten Switch-Games.
Ah, aber bei der Auflösung merk ich ein leichtes, leichtes Input-Lag.
Und die Steuerung spackt ein bisschen.
Nintendo Switch Online, nein, das geht natürlich nicht.
Das geht natürlich nicht.
Nintendo Switch Online funktioniert natürlich nicht.
Das wär's jetzt auch.
Omega-Ludel.
Ja, du kannst da, du kannst da keinen Splatoon draufspielen und online cheaten oder sowas damit, weißt du?
Sowas würde ich aber auch, äh, nicht empfehlen, ne, man.
Was soll der Scheiß?
Nur Singleplayer.
Du kannst, äh, ältere Konsolen kannst du, kannst du spielen.
Ältere Konsolen kannst du spielen.
Sogar mit, sogar mit Netzwerk-Multiplayer.
Ja.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob Online-Netzwerk-Multiplayer.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn du einen Port weiterleitest.
Aber es gibt ja auch so Game-Server, zumindest gab es das früher, so Game-Server für alte Spiele, wo man online zusammenspielen konnte mit Matchmaking und sowas.
Ne, das hat so gut wie keinen Delay, wenn du das, wenn du die emulierten Sachen spielst.
Also mega, mega nice.
Stream-Delay, Quatsch.
Stream-Delay.
Kein Stream-Delay.
Wo sollten wir Stream-Delay haben?
Hehe.
Aber es ist richtig, also hättet ihr ernsthaft gedacht, dass die Switch in 1080p mit 60 FPS läuft?
Und dass du im Endeffekt sogar noch die Möglichkeit hast, ein paar Sachen anzuschalten, sodass es dann sogar besser aussieht als auf der originalen Switch?
Also das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Übrigens, ähm, PS3 funktioniert auch, allerdings funktioniert die PS3 nicht performant genug.
Also, ich hab's mit Uncharted ausgesucht.
Ich hab's probiert und Uncharted läuft nur mit 15 FPS, 15, 20 FPS.
Je nachdem, was man einstellt, auch ein bisschen mehr, aber nicht, dass es gut ist.
Hast du, wie fandest du meinen Gameboy S...
Du hast mir was geschrieben?
Äh, also den letzten Tweet, ich hab, ich hab, den letzten hab ich am 28. Januar gekriegt.
Als Antwort.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Welche CPU hast du?
Ja, Moment.
Moment, ich spiel das doch nicht auf meinem Desktop-Rechner.
Ach, das, das hab ich gesehen.
Ja, das ist ja schon 5 Tage her oder so.
Das war cool, das hab ich gesehen.
Das war nice.
Ich, ich hab aber nicht gedacht, dass du's wirklich gemoddet hast.
Ich dachte, das ist irgend so ein Meme-Bild, was du reingeschnitten hast.
Ich dachte nicht, dass das echt...
Doch, doch, jetzt, das musst du gleich...
Das hab ich gesehen, aber das ist ja schon 5 Tage her oder so.
Das war doch vor dem Wochenende, glaube.
Das hab, hab ich nicht sogar geliked.
Das machen wir heute übrigens nicht.
Kennt jemand...
IP-Überwachungskameras ohne irgendeinen Cloud-Registrierungsquatsch.
Ja, also, suchst du teure oder billige?
Wahrscheinlich billige, weil teure gibt's in Massen.
Äh, was ich selbst, was ich selbst habe, sind Amazon Reolink-Kameras.
Also, die versprühen jetzt nicht gerade super hochwertige Qualität, aber die funktionieren...
Also, nicht alle, aber die meisten funktionieren rein lokal.
Also, zum Beispiel, ich glaube, das könnte sogar sein, wo ich einen...
Davon hab.
Möglich, möglich, dass ich darf...
Also, so eine, die so ähnlich aussieht, hab ich.
Die funktioniert rein offline.
Und, äh, ich hab auch noch...
Von denen sowas in der Richtung mit zum Schwenken.
Da weiß ich aber aus dem Kopf nicht, welches.
Die funktionieren rein...
Die kannst du nicht flashen.
Aber die funktionieren rein offline mit RTSP.
Was ist hier wieder?
Buba-Vorschlag.
Die funktionieren offline rein mit RTSP.
Hast du die rund ums Haus?
Ja.
Also, ich hab...
Lass mal überlegen.
Wo, wo hab ich, wo hab ich, wo hab ich Kameras?
Ähm, die...
Das, das Einzige, die machen halt keinen super hochwertigen Eindruck, ja?
Also, ich hatte auch eine, die ist mir, die ist mir verreckt nach irgendwie einer Woche.
Die hab ich dann wieder zurück zu Amazon geschickt.
Ähm, also ich hab...
Lass mal überlegen.
Wo, wo hab ich einen Kam...
Ich mach einfach mal auf dem zweiten Bildschirm kurz die Kameraübersicht auf.
Da kann ich euch sagen, wo ich Kameras hab.
Muss ich mir an dem Kopf überlegen.
Also, ich hab einmal im Keller eine hängen.
Das ist eine geflashte.
Das ist keine...
Reolink-Kamera.
Das ist eine geflashte alte Wisecam.
Die zeigt mir den Wasserdruck von der Heizung an.
Da hab ich noch nichts Gescheites gefunden, wie ich das...
Ne, das verwende ich nicht.
Das verwende ich gar nicht, die Oberfläche.
Ich hab's mittlerweile direkt in Home Assistant integriert.
So, den Wasserdruck von der Kamera.
Dann hab ich einmal das Katzenklo von oben, dass ich...
Also, ich hab ja zwei Katzenklos.
Das obere Katzenklo hat eine Kamera drüber hängen am Schrank.
Probleme mit der Heizung ab und zu mal.
Jetzt mittlerweile schon nicht mehr.
Seitdem ich das Heizungsprofil richtig eingestellt hab.
Am Schrank überm Katzenklo, dass ich weiß, wenn die Katze mal wieder geschissen hat.
Unten am Eingang, beziehungsweise im Flur.
Auf der Terrasse im Hof.
Hab ich eine, die ist schwenkbar.
Dass ich quasi Hof und Terrasse mitbekomm.
Dann hab ich eine zum Hoftor.
Und eine für das Hoftor.
Kameras aufm Klo.
Ja, aber nicht auf meinem Klo.
Aufm Katzenklo.
Denn die ist...
Es ist nicht so, dass ich unbedingt scharf drauf wäre, meine Katze beim Kacken zu beobachten.
Es ist aber gut zu sehen, wenn sie drauf war.
Weil wenn die Katze drauf war und du nicht schnell genug bist, kommt sie an und erzählt dir, dass du nicht schnell genug gewesen bist.
Hast du auch welche, die Audio übertragen?
Ja, ich glaub, die ganzen Reolink-Kameras können Audio übertragen.
Das benutze ich aber nicht.
Hab ich auch direkt nicht weitergeleitet, den Audio-Stream.
Brauch ich nicht. Brauch kein Audio.
Das Einzige, wo ich Audio brauche, ist, äh, theoretisch, ist die Tür-Gegensprecheranlage.
Und die hatte ich mal eine Weile angezapft über so eine Siedle, Siedle, äh, äh, tja, so, so, so, so, so, so ein Siedle-Smart-Dings-Gerät, was ich mir auf Ebay gekauft hab.
Aber ich hab festgestellt, ich benutze diese Gegensprechfunktion nie.
Also ich benutze die Gegensprechfunktion, wenn ich daheim bin, von den zwei Telefonen, also von den zwei Tür-Gegensprecheranlagen, die an der Wand hängen.
Aber dieses Weiterleiten aufs Handy...
Äh, und aufs Deck-Telefon hab ich nie benutzt, deswegen hab ich wieder abgebaut.
Das Einzige, was ich jetzt habe noch, ist, wenn eine klingelt an der Haustür, dann ruft sie mich auf dem Handy an.
Aber nicht, dass ich mit dem reden kann, sondern bekomme ich per SIP einen Video-Feed geschickt von meiner Kamera am Hoftor, dass ich sehe, wer davor steht.
Auch wenn ich unterwegs bin.
Also wenn ich Bock hab, kann ich auf dem Handy annehmen und dann sehe ich, wer vor der Tür steht.
Aber selbst das werde ich wahrscheinlich abschaffen, weil...
Das benutze ich auch viel zu wenig, als dass sich die Existenz rechtfertigt.
Nö.
Wir haben halt gar keine Tür-Gegensprecher...
Achso, ja, das stimmt.
Wobei ich mich auf die Qualität nicht so...
Ja, weiß nicht.
Sag mal, kann sich die Musik mal entscheiden, wie laut die jetzt sein möchte?
Wieder zu leise, die wissen es nicht.
Also die Qualität dieser Reolink-Kameras und Mikrofone...
Zum Hören vielleicht, aber zum Gegensprechen...
Das Gegensprechen auch nur mit der offiziellen App funktioniert.
Wir haben zwar mal das Reolink...
Ne, ne, das war kein Reolink.
Hickvision war das.
Wir haben mal, falls sich noch jemand dran erinnert,
wir haben mal im Stream die Hickvision...
Das Hickvision-Gegensprech-Protokoll reverse-engineert.
Archiv, Wobblos, hier.
Hick-Vision, ne, Tür.
Nur ganz kurz, lol.
Tür, Türklingel plus Audio.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ist es das?
Ne, das ist die SIP-Geschichte.
Ähm...
Smart...
Vor zwei Jahren, mehr als ein...
Fängt gut an.
Ne, da habe ich irgendwas gebastelt.
Dann weiß ich nicht mehr.
Wir haben irgendwo, wir haben irgendwann mal das nachgebaut von Hickvision,
dieses Rücksprache, also Gegensprech-Protokoll.
Das war...
Auf ein, auf HTTP-basierendes...
Ne, wie kann man das am besten umschreiben?
Es basierte zum Teil auf HTTP.
Soll ich mal nach Gegensprechanlage, könnte man tatsächlich suchen.
Ja, das stimmt.
China-Kamera-Hexorn.
Gegensprechanlage.
Ja, genau das ist es.
Alter.
Wie, wie, wie...
Mordge, Mordge-Five-Hat-Time.
Guck, das, das haben wir damals gebaut.
Weiß nicht, wo man die anwendet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man die Anwendung irgendwo sieht.
Ach ja, die Katze, die Katze, wo haben wir dann übertragen?
Ja, hier sieht man, hier sieht man das Kamerabild.
Alter, wie lange haben wir da dann rumgemacht?
Fünfeinhalb Stunden, Mann.
So eine hässliche Klingel, genau.
Die habe ich nie benutzt.
Jupp.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Aber irgendwo hier haben wir das nachgebaut.
So, und das war ein ganz furchtbar ekliges Protokoll.
Das basierte auf HTTP.
Allerdings hat es...
Nicht HTTP direkt gesprochen.
Also, es hat einen HTTP-Request gemacht.
Und dann, wenn normalerweise die Verbindung abgebaut wurde,
hat es über TCP dann die Sprachdaten geschickt.
Also es hat irgendwie einen TCP-Handshake gemacht.
Irgendwie einen HTTP-Get.
Und danach hat es dann über TCP-Raw-Socket irgendwelche Daten gepusht.
Das war ein absolut Standard, nicht Standard-konformes China-Chinesen-Müll-Protokoll,
was die sich da ausgedacht haben.
Das konnte sich nur HickVision irgendwie ausdenken.
Ja, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das war so kaputt, dass man den normalen C-Sharp-HTTP-Client nicht verwenden konnte,
weil er sich richtig an die Verbindung immer geclosed hat.
Und man durfte die Verbindung nicht closen.
Danach ging es dann weiter.
Ganz, ganz ekliges Zeug.
Ich erinnere mich dunkel dran.
Ja.
Ja, also so sieht es aus.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sind wir da jetzt eigentlich drauf gekommen?
Gab es nicht letztens ein Video, wo eine Kamera versprochen hat,
nix zu sehen, ein paar Bayer-Shark hat jemand rausgeholt,
die sogar die Gesichtserkennung nach China funkt?
Ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Also, was relativ mittelgroßer Skandal war in dieser Runde,
war die Wisecam-Kameras,
wo Streams theoretisch für jeden einsehbar öffentlich im Internet gingen,
über irgendwelche...
China-Server, die haben gesagt, alles super-secure und verschlüsselt.
Und irgendjemand hat den China-Control-Server gefunden,
weil die selbst irgendwelche China-Cloud-Services verwenden.
Und da konnte jemand, der den Server kannt und die richtigen URLs aufgemacht hat,
quasi jede Kamera sich von jedem auf der Welt, der das über die Cloud schickt, angucken.
Ich war natürlich nicht betroffen, weil ich meine Kameras geflasht habe.
Wo wir wieder dabei sind,
du kannst den Herstellern halt absolut nichts trauen.
Manchmal glaube ich, die Hersteller wissen es selber,
und lassen sich halt von den eigentlichen Produzenten dieser Kameras zuschwätzen.
Ja, Eufy war letztens, was ich meine, das ist Wisecam-Skandal-Suchen.
Schon wieder!
Ja, das, das, das...
Ja, ja, du konntest aber auch schon, du konntest, das ist auch schon drei Jahre her.
Also ganz im Ernst, die Leute lernen es nicht, gell?
Das ist das Gleiche, das ist das Gleiche wie mit Cloud-Passwort-Managern.
Die lernen es einfach nicht.
Bei jedem Breach oder bei jedem, bei jedem Sicherheitsproblem
freuen sich die Leute, oh, das ging aber nochmal gut.
Entweder waren meine Daten nicht dabei,
oder sie waren ja wenigstens noch verschlüsselt oder sonst was in der Richtung.
Und die Einschläge kommen immer näher, und die Leute reden sich das schön.
Und irgendwann betrifft es dann halt mal ihren gewählten Cloud-Passwort-Manager,
oder? Und dann, dann fallen sie aus allen Wolken, so.
Wie? Meine Passwörter in der Cloud speichern war doch keine so gute Idee.
Ja, das wundert mich jetzt aber.
Da sind die Leute wirklich selbst dran schuld.
Also wer seine Passwörter in der Cloud speichert, ich kann...
Ich, ich werde, ich werde jetzt nie verstehen, wie man das machen kann.
Also ich weiß nicht, doch, doch, ich verstehe, wie man das machen kann,
weil, weil es komfortabel ist und sich automatisch quasi so synkt auf alle Geräte.
Ohne wirklich zu synken, weil alle auf den gleichen Datenbestand zugreifen.
Aber ich würde nie im Leben meine Passwörter in der Cloud speichern.
Nie, bei irgendeinem Anbieter.
Das Einzige, was eventuell in Frage kommt, wäre, wenn ich wirklich meine Passwörter unterwegs brauche,
dann würde ich die selbst verschlüsseln und nur den Teil der Passwörter, die ich unterwegs brauche,
ähm, ja, verschlüsselt auf irgendeinen Cloud-Drive legen.
Wenn es unbedingt sein müsste. Am besten auf irgendeine eigene Kiste.
Aber am besten, es ist, es ist wie mit allem.
Wenn man seine Daten nicht irgendwie rausgegeben hat, dann kann einem auch nichts passieren.
Hehehe.
Ja, ja, da gab es auch letztens bisschen Diskussionen, dass Bitworn-Server-seitige Rotations nichts bringen und sowas.
Ich erinnere mich.
Kann man, kann man alles machen, kann man alles machen.
Also, wisst ihr, was ich mache?
Also, wie, wie ich das handhabe bisher, mit Accounts, wo ich die Passwörter mobil brauche,
ich tippe die einmalig ein und speichere sie in dem Passwort-Safe von meinem iPhone.
Kann man sich jetzt fragen, traut man Apple oder nicht?
Nein, ich traue Apple auch nicht.
Aber das sind meistens jetzt nicht so die, also, wenn ich sie speichere,
wenn ich sie speichere, dann sind das meistens eh nicht so die allerwichtigen Sachen.
Und ansonsten, also Scalable zum Beispiel, habe ich, habe ich gespeichert im Handy, ja,
weil ich sonst den Mist immer wieder eingeben muss.
Aber Scalable, ja, es könnte einer meine Stonks verkaufen, aber da mache ich mir jetzt weniger Gedanken drüber.
Ähm, ansonsten habe ich,
wichtige Sachen eigentlich nicht gespeichert auf dem Handy.
Das habe ich einmalig eingegeben, dass die App sich authentifiziert, Amazon zum Beispiel.
Amazon habe ich einmalig authentifiziert auf dem Handy und dann ist gut.
Reicht.
Geh wieder auf YouTube.
Ja, Booba-Time.
YouTube meint, das sollen wir unbedingt gucken.
Aber das juckt mich nicht.
Mich juckt nicht, ob jemand einen Song für Amorant gemacht hat.
Der Chain-Lore geht wieder ab.
Alexi-Bexi-Video.
Ich weiß...
Ich habe nichts persönlich gegen den.
Ich kenne ihn nicht.
Wir haben uns nie irgendwo gesehen, aber ich mag seine Videos einfach nicht.
Ich kann mir das nicht angucken.
Was können wir uns denn angucken?
Ich habe übrigens ein interessantes Video, ein interessantes Video gefunden.
Und zwar das hier.
Ackerman-Kram.
Der berichtet über exakt das, was ich auch erzählt habe in meinem Video.
Fällt euch...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Kommt euch...
Was ist das denn?
Kommt euch diese Mail irgendwie bekannt vor?
Habt ihr sowas ähnliches schon mal gesehen?
Also, falls ihr mein Video gesehen habt.
Also, ich bin anscheinend nicht der Einzige, der solche Scam-E-Mails bekommen hat.
Ansonsten ist jetzt die YouTube-Empfehlung nicht so super spannend.
Was ist das denn?
Windows XP Steam Deck.
Okay, bei dem Titel ist doch der Chebat...
Der Chebat eigentlich fast schon voll.
Vorprogrammiert, oder?
Da erwartest du eigentlich schon, Chebated zu werden.
Mein New Desktop.
Was ist das?
Das ist kein E3.
Was ist das für ein Window Manager?
Desktop.
Mein Vater hat früher immer gesagt Desktop.
Ich glaube, er weiß bis heute nicht, dass es Desktop heißt.
Desktop.
Ranking Linux Environments.
Oh, nee.
Das ist der Firefox.
Das ist doch der Firefox-Dude, oder?
Das ist doch der Firefox-Dude, der in einem Video erzählt hat, dass er es nicht mehr irgendwie vertreten kann, Firefox zu benutzen.
Und dann hat er zwei Wochen später ein Video gemacht.
Ich benutze wieder Firefox.
Das ist der doch, oder?
Sekunde.
Hat YouTube nicht mal einen Suchen-Knopf?
Firefox.
Hier.
I'm leaving Firefox.
Genau.
Und dann hat er einen Monat später ein Video gemacht.
Was not fun.
Er ist wieder bei Firefox zurück.
Alles klar.
Hey, everyone.
Vor allem, seriously.
Der wollte diesen räudigen Gnome-Default-Browser verwenden.
Echt.
Was jedem von uns im Stream sofort klar war, dass es nicht funktionieren wird.
Ich meine, das heißt nicht nur, dass man sowas nicht probieren kann.
Aber in dem Fall.
Es gibt doch keinen nennenswerten Browser neben Firefox und Chrome.
Ich warte jetzt drauf, bis die Apple-Fanboys kommen.
Das ist alles Chrome, Leute.
Brave ist Chrome.
Opera ist Chrome.
Edge ist Chrome.
Das zählt für mich alles rein.
Aber hier, er hat recht.
Was ist denn mit Safari?
Tja.
Safari taugt leider nichts.
LibriWolf ist Gecko.
Ja, dann ist es Firefox.
Ich sag doch, es gibt keinen nennenswerten Browser neben Firefox und Chrome.
Safari ist Müll.
Safari ist, was Webstandards angeht, so weit hinten dran.
Aus mehreren Kombinationen.
Ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, woran es hundertprozentig liegt.
Also einmal möchte Apple einiges nicht unterstützen.
Weil Apple beispielsweise sowas wie PWA's halt nicht mag auf dem iPhone.
Weil halt im Zweifelsfall die ein bisschen Konkurrenz machen zu ihrem App Store.
Was ist denn das?
Oh, das habe ich auf Hacker-News gelesen.
Das habe ich auf Hacker gelesen.
Carbon.
Carbon-Null.
Das ist...
Docker...
Okay.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus, Leute.
Docker run.
Dings.
Bam.
Wir gucken uns jetzt YouTube im Terminal an.
YouTube in Docker im Terminal.
Und wisst ihr, was der Schlimme ist?
Das funktioniert auch noch halbwegs.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das funktioniert.
Vollständiges YouTube im Terminal.
Ohne Ads.
Nee, mit Ads.
Ich meine, man erkennt den Channel.
Was ist das?
Das ist Carbon.
Carbon-Null.
Irgendjemand hat Firefox.
Nee, Chrome?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Was hat er genommen?
Chrome.
Der hat irgendwie einen neuen Render.
Neuen Render.
Neuen Renderer eingebaut in Chrome oder sowas.
Und hat halt als Output was genommen, was man auch im Terminal rendern kann.
Guck mal.
Jetzt können wir uns Werbung...
Pixelated YouTube Werbung angucken.
Poggers.
Ey gut, Sound haben wir hier nicht.
Alles klar, oder?
Settings.
Also Text und so wird wirklich gut gerendert.
Kann man nichts sagen.
1044p.
Nee, Leute.
Wenn man das weiß,
dass es Battlefield 4 ist,
könnte man dazu geneigt sein,
zu erkennen, dass es Battlefield 4 ist.
Oder?
Also wenn man es weiß.
Wenn man es nicht weiß,
erkennt man es ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ja.
So kann ich sogar Booba-Videos gucken im Stream.
Da könnte ich sogar auf Porn hab.
Und man würde nichts erkennen im Stream.
Funktioniert Twitch?
Bestimmt.
Bestimmt funktioniert Twitch.
Oh, da muss ich...
Twitch.
.tv slash Wobblors aufmachen.
Ach ja.
Okay.
Also Twitch funktioniert nicht.
Was mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt wundert.
Ich würde ja gerne Cookies accepten, wenn es funktioniert.
Was steht hier drauf?
Save Changes.
Perfekt.
Accept Cookies.
Manage Cookies.
Okay.
Wir accepten...
Wir accepten einfach alles.
Nielsen.
Das ist super.
Gibt es nicht so was wie...
Gibt es nicht einfach so, wie alles accept man...
Dann geht das bestimmt auch, wenn man Cookies acceptet.
Weil der Cookies accepten Knopf ist kaputt.
Okay.
Okay, funktioniert nicht.
Aber es ist unglaublich, wie viele einzelne Leute mit guten Ideen hinbekommen, oder?
Twitch will das nicht wegen Ads.
Twitch merkt das doch gar nicht.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Chrome.
Twitch weiß doch nicht, wohin...
da kaum rendert.
Du kannst da drin theoretisch alles anschauen.
Aber schon mega nice, oder?
Dass sowas funktioniert.
FFM-Pack installiert.
Wozu?
Außerdem habe ich FFM-Pack installiert, aber es hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Chain-Lore
will wieder Temp
timeoutet werden.
Auch wenn das Bild
nichts Schlimmes ist.
Aber er muss es immer austesten.
Sei froh, dass der Patrick
nicht da wäre. Der hätte schon längst wieder Temp gebannt.
Alter, wie oft wollen die uns noch
dieses Booba-Video... Ich will das
Booba-Video nicht sehen, Mann!
YouTube, kannst du mich in Ruhe
lassen? Okay, geht.
Hast du von dem was auch immer
und noch was was auch immer
Leak mitbekommen?
Nee. Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Leak der
Phone-Forensik-Tools. Aha.
Habe ich noch nie...
Habe ich noch nie mitbekommen.
Den letzten größeren Leak,
den ich mitbekommen habe, war glaube ich der
GTA-6-Leak.
Oh, ich glaube, das war so das letzte
große Ding, wo ich mich dran erinnern kann.
War das auch schon...
Nee, wobei, das kann nicht sein. Das ist ja schon wieder
ein Jahr her. Da gab es in der Zwischenzeit
schon 800 neue Leaks.
Hast du das mitbekommen? Das habe ich mitbekommen.
Argentinische Pesos und PayPal.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was... Das habe ich
auf jeden Fall mitgekriegt.
Wo wir gerade bei Tricks sind...
Wisst ihr, was mir aufgefallen ist?
Ähm...
Also, ich habe ja YouTube-Premium.
Ich habe YouTube-Premium
allerdings über
einen Account,
der ein Payment-Profil
in Indien hat.
Das heißt, ich bezahle
irgendwie 300 indische
Rupien, was irgendwie
4 Euro sind.
Oder 3,5 Euro versus
14 Euro. So, und wisst ihr, was mir jetzt aufgefallen
ist? Und zwar
in YouTube-Premium, das wusste ich bis jetzt gar nicht,
ist YouTube
Music Premium.
Oder Premium mit drin.
Was im Endeffekt bedeutet,
dass ich Amazon
Unlimited Music jetzt gekündigt habe.
Gucke ich einfach über YouTube,
wenn es eh im Preis schon drin ist.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Never subbed, never donated, Adblock on,
laptop, never swiped.
Wobei es da noch bessere Versionen von gibt.
Bis jetzt habe ich alles
gefunden, was ich gesucht habe.
Das einzig Blöde ist,
aber damit hätte ich rechnen können,
das einzig...
Das einzig...
Richtig, genau, das wollte ich gerade sagen.
Das einzig Blöde ist, wenn du auf aktuelle Sachen
gehst, kriegst du irgendwelche
Bollywood-Charts vorgeschlagen.
Das ist aber nicht weiter wild,
weil du kannst in die verschiedenen Genres
gehen, dann ist das alles okay und
das lernt nach wie vor, was du gerne hörst und
kriegst dann kaum indische Sachen. Wenn du aber guckst
top aktuell, dann kriegst du irgendwelche
indische, indischen Pop vorgeschlagen,
wenn du indischen Account hast.
Wen juckt's? Dafür kostet es einfach
10 Euro weniger.
Ups. Nein, nein, nein. Zweimal starten geht nicht.
Dann ist es broken.
Oh, geht das? Geht das noch?
Ja, geht noch. Guck dir das mal an,
wenn du das nämlich hast, brauchst du kein Spotify
mehr, du brauchst kein Unlimited mehr.
Funktioniert alles, funktioniert alles gut.
Ich hab vorhin gesehen,
mein Lieblings-C-Sharp-Content-Creator
hat ein neues Video.
Wollte ich mir nachher eh angucken.
Es gibt nämlich in C-Sharp
12 gibt es neue
Constructors. Vielleicht gucken wir uns das später
noch an. Kann ich übrigens,
sein Content kann ich nur empfehlen. Also wenn ihr,
äh, .NET verwendet, beziehungsweise
C-Sharp-Entwickler seid oder euch die Plattform
interessiert, der macht wirklich gute Videos zu.
Warum ist dein Twitch-Chat so komisch?
Du meinst der hier?
Ganz einfach.
Weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
In meinem Vorschau auf dem
zweiten Monitor sehe ich das.
Noch überhaupt nichts
Instabiles gemerkt bisher.
Na gut, der refresht
nur einmal die Sekunde.
Du kannst es auch höher stellen, dass er alle
alle 500 Millisekunden refresht.
So was. Der refresht einmal in der Sekunde.
Also wenn du jetzt beispielsweise die
Anzeige, also wenn du hier die oben die Anzeige hast,
ob deine NumLog-Taste gedrückt ist,
dann dauert das, dann dauert das mal ein bisschen
kurz. Aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Einmal die Sekunde Update von der Statusbar
reicht doch.
Finde ich gut. Ich finde aber die Features nice.
Vielleicht gebe ich mir doch mal irgendwann
Polybar oder sonst was.
Aber bis jetzt bin ich eigentlich ganz
zufrieden mit meiner billigen Statusleiste.
Aber was heißt billig? Trotzdem nice, was alles
angezeigt wird.
Das Arch, by the way, selbstverständlich.
Doch, kannst du.
Aber anscheinend
denkt YouTube Musik trotzdem, du bist in Indien.
Ne, braucht man nicht.
Polybar, das kannst du
für sowas wie für Statusleisten zum Beispiel
verwenden. Nur, dass du dann noch coolere Sachen
machen kannst, so Lautstärke, Anzeige
und alles mögliche. Brauchen
tut man das nicht wirklich.
Wenn man gerne rumbastelt, ist es vielleicht ganz cool.
Yep, Clock.
Anything you code, I'll pay for.
Oh, das ist so schnell geschnitten.
Ist das ein...
Alter, was ist mit den Leuten los?
Ist das ein Software-Entwicklungs-Influencer?
Nein, ja und nein.
Zoomer-Content, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Tja.
The most powerful software development process
is the easiest.
Kommt auf die Software an, würde ich behaupten.
Soll ich mal sagen.
Der most powerful software development process
ist der, der passt zu dem, was man entwickeln will.
YouTube gehen auch langsam echte Ideen aus, oder?
Youtube gehen auch langsam echte Ideen aus, oder?
Was ich gucken will. Das ist immer das gleiche Kram.
Und ehrlich gesagt...
Ich benutze zwar Thunderbird.
Aber die Zukunft von Thunderbird,
die interessiert mich auch nicht so wahnsinnig.
Wie kriegst du die Transparenz hin?
Du meinst das hier?
Ach, hier oben.
Hier oben?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen dreckreich.
reich, das... Jet, wer von
euch hat gerade meinen Twitch-Account geöffnet?
Ah, okay, dann weiß ich aber, was es war.
Ne, ich bin aus Versehen wahrscheinlich einfach hier drauf
gekommen. Was ist denn ein
Nicht-Real-DNS? Keine Ahnung, wie du
da drauf kommst jetzt. Äh, was du machen
musst, ist folgendes, wenn du es transparent machen willst.
Ähm...
Das hier musst du machen. Guck mal.
Das musst du einfügen.
Einfügen. I3-Bar
Command I3-Bar minus T.
Das minus T ist wichtig, weil das
minus T für Transparency steht.
Und wenn du das so machst, dann
funktioniert es. Dann ist deine Bar auch
transparent. Vorschau war ein Video
mit einem Real-DNS. Keine Ahnung.
Ja, zu spät.
Jetzt habe ich schon zugemacht. Oder meinst
du hier Real-DNS?
You want a Real-DNS-Server
at home? Ah, okay.
Der erzählt dir wahrscheinlich, dass du
Bind verwenden kannst und 30
Milliarden Optionen zum Einstellen hast.
Ich glaube, mit Real
meint er nicht, dass
das der einzige DNS-Server ist, der
richtiges DNS macht.
Sondern er meint, das ist quasi ein
echter DNS-Server. Also quasi
nicht einfach nur so ein Spielzeug-DNS-Server,
sondern einer, der
alles kann und Millionen
Client-Requests kann und sowas.
Ich meine, Bind ist ja seit
40 Jahren
oder so der DNS-Server schlechthin.
Leider von der Konfig auch abfuck.
Ab-fuck-es-fuck.
Die Bind-Konfig.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das stimmt nicht.
Also es sind alle YouTube-Server,
YouTube-Videos im Katalog.
Also du kannst auf YouTube
Music auch automatisch
alle YouTube-Videos
gucken, wo die als
Musik gefleckt sind. Aber die haben auch noch mehrere
Sachen. Zum Beispiel
habe ich letztens gehört, und das ist bestimmt nicht
public auf YouTube, habe ich
gehört, in Flames.
So. Okay, das hat irgendein
Dude hochgeladen, aber ich hab mir nicht
das Album in
einem Stück angehört, sondern
Wait a minute, der Kram ist public
auf YouTube? Kann doch nicht sein.
Nee, das kann...
Okay, okay.
Jetzt mal richtig cringing, cringing
Power-Metal suchen.
Der kann doch nicht public auf YouTube
sein. Na, teilweise.
Aber nicht das, aber nicht das,
nicht das gesamte Album.
Nicht das, nee, nee, nee. Du hast schon
noch extra, du hast schon noch extra Tracks.
Also ich hab bisher alles das,
was ich auf Amazon sonst gehört hätte, auch bei
YouTube Music gefunden.
Und der Katalog soll auch in den
relativ gut sein. Ich hab... Ja.
Tatsächlich.
Ja, Moment.
Weil ich hier eingeloggt bin.
Ach, ja Moment, das ist die
Free-Version. Was du jetzt
gezeigt hast, ist die Free-Version
von Google Music. Ja.
Was auch immer. Ehrlich gesagt ist mir's egal.
Ich hab bisher alles,
was ich bei Amazon gehört hab, auch auf YouTube
gefunden. Hast du das Video von
Tim Gabel mit
Morpheus gesehen? Nee.
Um was ging's da?
Nicht, dass ich das lohne, anzugucken.
Okay, lass mal, komm, wir müssen jetzt, wir müssen jetzt
noch mal ein bisschen was...
Windows XP Steep... Okay, ich will einfach wissen,
wie gebetet wir werden.
Ach so, jeder macht
irgendwelche Chat-GPT-Videos, man.
Ich kann's bald nicht mehr sehen.
Gut, es geht halt auch einfach gut gerade.
Wir gucken jetzt das hier.
Das ist nur ein Remote-Screen.
Dann gucken wir mal, wie
gebetet wir werden.
Ich skippe, ich skippe da mal drüber.
Okay. Unboxing.
Okay.
Das sieht, das sieht aber wirklich
nach Budget aus.
Das Ding. What the fuck?
Mein Name...
Du willst doch nicht seriously da drauf spielen,
auf diesem Controller.
Das sieht aus wie ein Navigationsgerät.
Ja, ich wollte... Ohne Scheiß,
Yandari, das dachte ich mir auch gar nicht.
Sieht aus wie ein fucking Navigationsgerät.
GMA 900!
Lull! Alter!
Ich weiß doch gar nicht,
was ist denn ein Celeron
MULV?
GMA 900, da weißt du schon,
das ist von...
2008 oder so.
Discount... Ja, sag ich doch!
Lull!
Das ist das Ausbildungsdatum 2005.
Es ist nur 6545 Tage alt.
Wir haben...
Ich glaube, wir haben sogar...
Ah, wir haben das nicht animierte Badchest.
...Following year.
And the specs are very much representative of that time.
But that's by no means a bad thing.
Featuring an Intel Celeron M...
Ich sprühe ein bisschen vor.
...which borderline makes it a
Pentium 3 style experience.
With a bit of extra power saving tech in there
Was will er eigentlich damit?
Ich meine, das erste Kiste von 2005.
Damit kannst du, darauf läuft wahrscheinlich mit Achon Krahma Half-Life 1 von 1998 eine ordentliche Auflösung.
The question is now, I've not tested this, the seller hadn't either, does ours and don't have them on hand, among many other things.
The original operating system was a Samsung version of Windows XP Slow.
It took 16 hours to copy a...
Haha, fuck alle.
Also, du kannst davon ausgehen, wenn das Installieren von Windows XP 16 Stunden dauert,
da läuft da schlicht und ergreifend nix drauf.
16 Stunden, man.
Wenn wir Windows XP in der VM installieren, dauert das 8 Minuten.
Oder so.
Quatsch, 3 Minuten.
3 Minuten, das ist...
Flup, ist das fertig.
Was meint ihr, wie lange eine Windows XP Installation auf meinem neuen PC braucht?
Ratet mal.
Win Future, genau, das brauche ich.
Äh.
Okay, perfekt.
Wo ist es?
Die 120-Tage-Testversion von Windows XP.
Wo ist denn der Download jetzt überhaupt?
Archive.
Ja.
Der Download ist da, wo du ihn nicht findest.
Wie gab es...
Es gab doch gar kein SP3.
Es gab doch gar kein SP...
Doch, gab es?
Dann war Windows 7.
Ach, auf der linken Seite.
Dann war Windows 7 das, oder?
Ja, Download starten.
Okay, so.
Bist wohl noch zu jung, das wird es gewesen sein, ja.
So, jetzt mal gucken.
Mal gucken, wie schnell geht Windows XP auf meiner Kiste.
Ich hatte sogar die XP-Beta damals installiert.
Neue virtuelle Kiste.
So, Custom.
Okay.
Next.
Installer-Disk.
Ne, ohne.
Legen wir nachher ein.
Installer-Disk.
Windows XP.
Gucken, ob das hier noch drinsteht.
Professional Edition.
Moment.
X64 laden?
Ich habe noch nie Windows XP X64 installiert.
Wusste gar nicht, dass das überhaupt ein Ding ist, dass es das überhaupt gegeben hat.
Na gut.
Next.
Wie viele Kerne kann Windows XP?
4?
Ah, 4G RAM sollte reichen.
Na.
Next.
Great Disk.
40G reicht auch.
Next.
Und Finish.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie schnell geht das?
Warum ist das doppelt jetzt da?
Man weiß es nicht.
Download.
Soundkarte lassen wir drin.
Auf geht's.
Windows XP Speedrun.
I finished installing.
Okay, wer timet?
Wer timet?
20.28 und 30.30 Uhr.
Okay, ich habe es.
Ich habe es.
Und natürlich noch 20.28 und 30 Sekunden.
Moment.
Ah.
Stretch.
Okay.
So.
Enter.
Agree.
Aggree-Ge.
Unpartition Space .
Quick.
Alter, warum ist denn das so langsam?
Das geht auf jeden Fall, das geht auf jeden Fall schneller, wenn man die richtigen Settings
hat.
Ich meine, was, was ist denn hier los?
Was ist das?
Ach.
files ok ok allein schon allein schon das hat das hat uns irgendwie fünf minuten gedauert warum wir
windows xp installieren weil ich wissen wie schnell es ist vor allem die x64 version das
habe ich noch nie gesehen 39 minuten das steht immer da das kenne ich noch von früher steht
immer 39 minuten da ok ab jetzt ab jetzt zählt eigentlich richtig so also 9 29 30 29 30 ich
schreibe es mir mal auf 29 30 so also ich tippe drauf das dauert nicht länger als vier minuten
dann ist das installiert es könnte von den haarissen im mainboard kommen ja vier minuten
leute aber was macht er denn so lang jetzt ok ok next blubb ja was auch immer oh shit das ging ja
damals noch nicht man konnte ja damals noch nicht installieren ohne key ne ne ne ne ne ne das
machen wir hier nicht irgendwelche illegalen sachen machen wir im stream nicht
gut wir können kein speedrun von windows xp machen da habe ich ja gar nicht mehr daran
gedacht dass man da noch so komische dinge wie cd keys gebraucht hat dann dann löschen
wir die virtual machines wieder ok empty und tschüss kein scoring auf dem leaderboard da
fiel's batman ok wie sind wir da drauf gekommen
okay ist wenn fairly well to be wrong deleted it why not install ends cool up samsung aus dem
what to do bar ist back in english oh we're back in english yes er versucht da keine windows xp
zu aktivieren ist ein mixtur russisch und englisch beobachten ist englisch es hat
chance to english hat er der complete oem samsung mp1 windows xp tablet edition install running
service pack 2
das hat mit dem steam deck wahrscheinlich mal so absolut gar nichts zu tun
mal ganz davon abziehen dass er nicht archie lux by the way drauf läuft
hat der fraps drauf
ja
zeiten von der
wahl hat man das gemacht
du weißt du weißt das was absolut alter du weißt das was richtig sagt wenn es quake 3 in
640 x 480 nur 68 fps schafft
drei
settings in
die resolution
der
intensiv benchmark segment we mostly
saw over 60 fps in and around that mark and during online or offline games this could even be
slightly higher
just about playable
24 fps morrowind
really cool it fantastic as this is really a rather intensive
gut man muss sagen man muss sagen morrowind wie die ganzen elder scrolls games lief jetzt nicht so super gut beim rauskommen ja
aber ich meine morrowind ist von wann 2003 oder so
also
sido ich sechs jahre neu
also das ding ist sechs jahre neue
game
man muss sich über die
es wichtig ist also dass das tablet noch genau so wie die elder scrolls games
was die nokia engage
and here in towns just didn't look as good
b 480 resolution
through the intro screen we could see slight dips below 60 fps
however this rear
ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie beeindruckend damals
Diese Unreal-Grafik-Demo mit Wassereffekten und so.
Ich glaube, das war das Beeindruckendste,
was ich je in meinem Leben grafisch gesehen habe.
Also zum damaligen Zeitpunkt.
Also rein vom Impact her, was es gemacht hat.
Die Unreal-Wir-Fliegen-Hier-Rum-Demo.
Es gab so ein paar Momente, wo ich sagen muss,
die haben mich grafisch umgehauen.
Also Far Cry 1 war auch mega krass, als es rausgekommen ist.
Vor allem lief es.
Also Far Cry 1 hatte natürlich ordentliche Hardware-Anforderungen
bei Release, aber das war jetzt kein Game,
was rausgekommen ist, was du nicht spielen konntest.
Ähm, Crysis.
Doch, das Remastered geht auf jeden Fall so.
Und ansonsten...
Also ich muss sagen, Crysis hat mich nicht so umgehauen,
wie Far Cry 1.
Aber Far Cry 1 ist ja auch quasi so der Vater von Crysis.
Ansonsten, es gab schon durchaus coole Sachen,
aber so wirklich umgehauen hat mich, glaube ich, nie wieder was,
wie die Unreal-1-Demo.
So, Unreal-Graphic-Demo.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Unreal-1, bitteschön.
Oder den Benchmark.
Graphics-Benchmark.
Ich glaube...
Was hier?
Nee, Unreal Tournament.
Nee, nee, nee.
Dieser Canyon...
Ja!
Das hier.
Leute, ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen,
wie das damals die Leute beeindruckt hat.
Ich meine, seriously,
das sieht doch jetzt sogar noch ganz brauchbar aus.
Wahrscheinlich läuft es in der Auflösung,
wie das damals keiner gespielt hat.
Aber ich meine, das war 1997 oder sowas.
Oder wann kam Unreal?
Unreal 1 oder 99?
98, wie Half-Life.
Ich meine, das sieht heute noch irgendwo brauchbar aus, ja?
Unreal 1 war übrigens auch wieder ab und zu das beste Unreal.
Und was mich damals auch total geflasht hat,
ist so diese Spiegelung auf der Brücke.
Wobei das ja überhaupt keine echte Spiegelung war.
Das hat die Leute damals umgehauen.
Vor allem das Wasser, was jetzt gleich kommt.
Guck mal hier, das Wasser.
Das Wasser hat einen richtig vom Mecker gehauen.
Guck mal hier, Wasser.
Da hat sich nichts großartig gespiegelt.
Das kam erst später.
Hat so ein bisschen Fake-Spiegelung gehabt.
So Nebel und...
Wassereffekte und so.
So Beleuchtung.
Also ich glaube, mich hat nie wieder grafisch so was umgehauen,
wie die erste Unreal-Grafik-Demo hier.
Fliegt der nicht noch durch den Turm?
Ja, entscheidend nicht.
Half-Life 2 war auch beeindruckend.
Ich glaube, es war besser als es raus war.
Aber mich hat nichts mehr so umgehauen, wie Unreal 1.
Also grafisch.
Unreal 1 war noch ein richtig gutes Game, fand ich.
Unreal 2 war komplett Kacke.
Und ich glaube, gab es überhaupt jemals ein Unreal 3?
Gab es das überhaupt mal?
Nee, oder?
Unreal 2 gab es, das war Müll.
Nee, Unreal Tournament gab es, aber...
Nö.
Unreal 3 gab es nie.
Hätte mich auch gewundert.
Hätte ich wahrscheinlich damals noch was von mitgekriegt.
Okay, jetzt lasst uns mal kurz das Cheatbaiting-Video fertig gucken.
Okay, Getting Online.
Half-Life, beste.
Das war ein Zeichen-Video.
Ich hab nur die Apps angeschlossen, mich nicht direkt zu gewöhnen.
Es ging dann wieder um wenn man Windows X,ows.
Wie er in Windows X oder Windows 4 auf den Markt kam.
Und ich sagte, es wird wieder ein Video geben.
Aber ich dachte nur, es wird wieder ein Video geben.
Und dann Черz.
Dann kam mein revitaler Mensch.
Vielleicht kommt ähnliche Erinnerungen.
Ich hatte keine Ahnung von dem, was es hier gerade noch gibt.
Ich wurde mir keine Ahnung von dem, was da jetzt noch ist, aber...
Ich habe mich entsprechend aufgehoben.
Wenn ich das jetzt kurz wiederum vorstand.
Ich glaube, es gibt eine Art und Weise, dass das in der Gotta-Taste besser geht.
Es wird schon wieder einfacher, weil wir es gerne machen.
aus XP Steam Deck.
Das ist jetzt ein guter Titel
für ein Video, aber
Leute, was haltet ihr denn
von, lasst mal
Clickbait-Titel
für das
Video.
Für
das Emulator-Video.
Was haltet ihr denn von
dieser Mini-PC emuliert
alles, sogar Switch?
Oder wie letztens
einer vorgeschlagen hat,
dieser Mini-PC
verändert dein Wohnzimmer.
Oder von Switch bis NES
alle Konsolen auf
einem Mini-PC.
Ne, das erste hat nicht ChatGPT gefragt.
Wir haben ChatGPT schon gefragt.
Die fand ich jetzt nicht so geil.
Wir haben letztens
ChatGPT schon gefragt.
Nintendo Switch in 4K und 120
FPS, ja das stimmt aber nicht.
Man kann Switch in Native-Auflösung
emulieren, mehr ist da
aber so
Du kannst bestimmt ein bisschen upscalen.
Aber das war's dann auch.
Ist egal, stimmt, der Titel muss ja nichts mit dem
Inhalt zu tun, aber das haben wir ja gelernt.
YouTubers
beware.
Ich bin, wir skippen
das jetzt mal, wir skippen das
jetzt mal schnell. Ich bin mal gespannt,
was der Kerl als besten
Desktop
Ich mein, wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
das ist auch der gleiche, der
gesagt hat, er kann Firefox nicht mehr verwenden
und einen Monat später hat er gesagt, er verwendet er nicht mehr.
Er verwendet wieder Firefox.
Wir skippen das jetzt, wir skippen da jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen vor.
Also, Sponsor?
But there are things that bug me
and that means it will be in
good and not in great.
Wir können einfach, wir können einfach
skippen. Wartet mal, wartet mal.
Wir gucken einfach mal. Hier, hier.
It's decent. Enlightenment
I never used at all.
Enlightenment, das habe ich früher benutzt. Weiß nicht, ob das mittlerweile
benutzbarer geworden ist.
And for me, tiling window managers
aren't desktops.
Was?
Okay, da hat er recht. Tiling window managers sind keine
desktops, aber tiling window manager
beste. Okay, was hat
er da? KDE ist
erst hier. Gnome und
äh, weiß ich nicht mal, was das für
ein Ding ist hier.
Ist auch okay.
Xfce, ist das made?
Ist das hier made?
Unity. Unity benutzt
Unity gibt's doch gar nicht mehr.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Das weiß ich, Elementary ist das.
Und das ist, das ist Cutefish
oder wie das heißt, gell? Das ist China
Cutefish OS.
Das ist China-Chinesen
Ubuntu-Aufsatz.
Ja, Cutefish OS.
Keine Ahnung, ob das taugt.
Der Elementary, Fanteon
oder so, Pantheon oder so,
genau, ja. Elementary Desktop.
Tja,
wisst ihr, ich muss ihm
da sogar,
bis hierhin irgendwie
zustimmen.
Hierzu kann ich nicht wirklich was sagen.
Hierzu auch nicht. Wahrscheinlich sind die noch schlechter.
Ich finde made, wenn das made,
made, made Desktop, wenn das
wirklich made ist, finde ich das, ja, das ist made.
Okay. Wenn das made ist und Xfce,
dann finde ich die durchaus brauchbar.
Unity kannst du knicken. Wird
glaube ich gar nicht mehr weiterentwickelt. Gucken wir mal.
GitHub, Unity, Linux.
Unity kommt wohl zu,
but why?
Was so eigentlich viel mit komponiert ist, wir haben viel auf
komponiertes laufen. Ich selber
hab an
den, an den Basic
Config Sachen vom Cluster allerdings so gut
wie nichts zu tun.
Ich mach mal irgendein Deployment und starte mal
irgendwas Neues oder sowas, aber es hält sich in Grenzen.
Wir haben aber viel auf
komponiertes und das funktioniert, seitdem wir es
managet haben in Azure, tatsächlich
auch ganz gut.
Ubuntu 23.04
erhält einen renovierten Linux Desktop.
Beautiful, efficient,
excellent. Ah, ne.
Elegant,
wie man das ausspricht.
Elegant
oder so. Ne, wie spricht
man das aus?
Elegant.
Ja, als wisst ihr es besser.
Bist du morgen live in Battlefield 2042?
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Aber ich muss morgen auf die Arbeit nach Frankfurt, also
wahrscheinlich erst so
wahrscheinlich erst so 18 Uhr.
Dann müssen wir morgen ein bisschen spielen, ich capture
was und dann nehme ich übermorgen
was zu auf. Okay, also was
gibt es? Unity blablabla
Luna Lobster.
Das ist mal ein guter Name für Ubuntu.
Oder, oder
sorry Leute, es heißt ja nicht Ubuntu.
Muss man korrekt aussprechen.
Unity ist wie ein offizieller Ubuntu Desktop.
Okay.
Es sieht immer noch aus wie das alte
Unity, beziehungsweise eigentlich
auch so wie das
Ubuntu Gnome.
Es ist immer noch die Frage, ist es eigentlich
Gnome oder ist es Gnome?
Aha, also ich habe
Unity ehrlich gesagt jetzt nicht sonderlich
nachgeweint. Ja, ansonsten
passt das, weil
außer das hier,
die würde ich nämlich auch allerhöchstens
durchschnittlich hinschreiben.
Ich mag nicht einen einzigen
Linux Desktop.
Am erträglichsten finde ich tatsächlich
noch so Sachen wie XFCE und
Mate, wenn es sein muss.
Ich mag keinen davon.
Also von denen hier nicht und von denen hier eigentlich auch nicht.
XFCE und Mate kann man sich noch am ehesten geben.
Vielleicht auch noch
sowas wie Openbox oder sowas.
Wobei das glaube ich da gar nicht
mit aufgeführt ist.
Ich mag auch keine Linux Oberfläche.
Das einzige, was ich gerne
benutze ist
tatsächlich i3.
i3 ist das einzige, was ich mir geben kann.
Und ich glaube das liegt daran,
und ich glaube das liegt daran,
weil
i3 halt nichts
hat, was einem in die Quere kommt.
i3
hat ja noch nicht mal wirklich Fenster.
Ich weiß, man kann Fenster, Fenster machen, aber
also i3 hat einfach
gar nichts so.
Und ich glaube das ist das, was mich
daran auch halt
nicht nervt.
Das es nichts hat, womit du dich auseinandersetzen musst.
Pullscreen für Dota 2.
Ok, na gut.
Muss ich nicht
unter Linux spielen.
Boah, das kann ich jetzt so umfassend
gar nicht beantworten.
Das hört sich für mich einfach nicht gut an zu benutzen.
Egal welche Linux-Desktops.
Die ganzen
Gnome-Based KDE
gefällt mir auch nicht.
Wie gesagt, am ehesten
geht da noch Mate und
XFCE oder sowas minimalistisches
wie Openbox oder Fluxbox gab es ja früher noch,
aber pff, ne.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, ok.
Ja, da gebe ich dir recht, ich glaube das
macht immer noch Probleme, aber ich hab's ja
stationär bei mir, für Beamer
und so. Ne, Dota 2,
also wenn ich in MOBA spielen würde, dann auf jeden Fall
Dota 2 und nicht LOL.
Was hast du
für einen Arbeits-PC?
Naja, nachdem ich viel Home-Office mache, ist das hier
mein Arbeits-PC. Der hier,
auf dem ich auch gerade streame.
Mit, mit, mit VMs.
Ich hab zum Beispiel,
ich hab für die Arbeit eine extra VM.
Auf der Arbeit habe ich ein Microsoft
Surface Book.
Drei ist es glaube ich.
Gibt es das?
Surface Book 3?
Ja, ich glaube so ein Ding habe ich auf
der Arbeit als Laptop.
Alter!
Softwaremonkeys.de
Alles klar.
Ah ne, schon, schon, schon
sinnvollere Preise.
Mac Online ist ein Microsoft Surface Book.
Jo, tja.
Naja, Moment, ich kann von meinem
Rechner nicht wirklich was machen.
Überall, also immer,
jedes Mal, wenn ich mich connecten muss,
wenn ich irgendwo wirklich wichtiges hin muss,
muss ich über
alle möglichen
Hürden.
Eine Bank, wo arbeitest du, sage ich nicht.
Hast du mal Sway ausprobiert?
Ja.
Und ich hab festgestellt, dass Wayland einfach nur
abgrundtief suckt in der VM.
Wayland unter VM, ja, funktioniert nicht.
Das fängt schon damit an,
dass der Screen
nicht refreshed
unter Wayland in der VM.
Standardmäßig.
Also, dann hat man nicht 1 FPS, sondern
man hat wirklich 0 FPS.
Das Screen refresht nur,
wenn man von Hand triggert.
Und das kann man aber beheben.
Das kann man beheben mit
irgendeinem Hack, den ich
auf GitHub gefunden hab.
Aber danach hast du das nächste Problem, dass
Copy & Paste beispielsweise nicht geht in der VM.
Und dann hört's bei mir halt auf.
Ich mein,
warum soll ich mich damit
auseinandersetzen, wenn
i3 und der X in der VM
einfach wunderbar funktioniert?
Wie findest du denn den Desktop von
Windows und Mac im Vergleich?
Also, ich muss dir sagen, ich hab Mac
noch nicht viel benutzt.
Ab und zu mal ein bisschen
rumgespielt mit.
Ich hatte mal
eine selbstinstallierte
Mac-Kiste auf so einem alten
Mini-PC.
Als das noch x86 war,
konnte man das ja ohne Probleme machen.
Das fand ich...
ganz okay.
Wobei ich nie über den Punkt rausgekommen bin,
dass ich mich an die anderen Shortcuts gewöhnt habe.
Das hast du wahrscheinlich, das Problem
hast du wahrscheinlich nach 2-3 Monaten
null. Alles in Fleisch
und Blut übergegangen. Aber ich bin da nie drüber rausgekommen.
Ich hatte sie aber auch nur ein bisschen zum Rumspielen
mit Mac. Also, ich muss sagen,
was macOS wirklich gut macht,
ist die Default-Config
und die Einheitlichkeit.
Also, du hast viele Programme,
die sich so
ins Betriebssystem integrieren, als gehören sie halt auch
dahin. Auch mit einheitlichen Shortcuts
und solchen Geschichten,
dass du immer weißt, was du drücken musst.
Und das es halt einfach wie aus einem Guss aussieht.
Das ist aber auch gleich...
ähm...
auch gleichzeitig eines der
Nachteile, macOS sieht halt
immer gleich aus. Egal
wo du hinguckst,
du klappst ein Mac auf und es sieht
aus wie macOS.
Der gleiche... den Farbton kann man
kla... wobei ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher, ob ich den Farbton überhaupt ändern kann.
Die gleichen Farbtöne
die exakt gleich...
alles, alles gleich.
Und die...
also was mir auch nicht gefallen hat
unter macOS ist das Fensterhandling.
So mit diesem...
ich weiß gar nicht, wie das war mit dem...
also gut, dass die Knöpfe auf der anderen Seite sind,
war jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Dass du nicht richtig die Fenster maximieren kannst,
ohne doppelt zu klicken.
Und dann, dass du komische 2 Sekunden Animationen hast
beim Fenster minimieren und so weiter.
Also, das Fensterhandling unter macOS hat mir nicht gefallen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich hab's auch nicht viel benutzt.
Joa...
Ansonsten kann ich nicht viel dazu sagen.
Windows Desktop ist auch absolut Kraut
und Rüben und für'n Arsch.
Ganz ehrlich, Windows 11 ist...
ist totaler Abfuck.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich Windows 11
ab ist das hier.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was die fucking...
Guck mal, ich weiß noch nicht mal, welche
Icons irgendwas bedeuten
sollen, dass ich wild rumklicken muss.
Weil wenn's einfach... ich mein...
Seriously...
Versteht irgendjemand Processes
unter 3 Quadraten?
3 mal Quadrat gleich Processes?
Aber...
Ja, gut. Aber trotzdem.
Aber trotzdem. Ja, jetzt, so ist's okay.
So ist's in Ordnung.
Aber macht man nicht einfach irgendwelche
selbsterklärenden Icons hin?
Bei mir sieht der noch aus wie früher.
Da hast du nicht die neueste Version.
Wobei, der sah doch eigentlich schon immer so aus,
der Windows 11. Also der Grund, warum ich Windows 11 hab,
ist das hier.
Weil nur Windows 11
meine Cores ordentlich
ansteuern kann.
Echt, ist das erst H22, H2?
Ja, Task Manager ist...
War nicht im Scope.
Deswegen hab ich das.
Ansonsten hätte ich auch keinen Bock auf Windows 11.
Man muss ja
sagen, Windows 11
ist, was diese Sache angeht, ein
bisschen
einheitlicher als Windows 10.
Allerdings manche Sachen
musste... Oh...
Musste immer noch hier drüber machen.
Ich kann mich jetzt
leider nicht mehr erinnern, was es
genau war. Aber beim Einrichten
musste ich auch ab und zu noch hier rein.
Ach ja,
ich weiß es wieder. Sound. Hier.
Ähm...
Dieses Menü gibt es keinen Ersatz für
unter Windows 11.
Im neuen
Design. Du hast
unter Windows 11, hast du die Sound-Settings.
Da geht aber nicht alles,
was hier drinnen geht.
Zum Beispiel kannst du hier drinnen...
Das geht zwar theoretisch hier drinnen
auch, aber funktioniert nicht.
Zum Beispiel kannst du hier
die unterstützten Formate an- und
abwählen.
Was hier drinnen zwar
theoretisch geht,
aber du kannst nur eins auswählen.
Also du kannst jetzt nicht sagen, das will
ich nicht. Was ich
aber haben will, weil
mein Audio-Interface kann
theoretisch, glaub...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es 192, ich glaube es ist 60...
Also mein Audio-Interface kann mehr,
das Problem ist nur,
wenn ich irgendwas anderes hier drüber ausgebe,
dann
stimmt es bei den anderen angeschlossenen Geräten nicht mehr
und knackst. Also das muss schon
passen dazu.
Und da musst du wieder in diese komische
Windows-Control-Panel-Kacke rein.
Ja, und ansonsten
wie gesagt, ich habe einen Surface Book 3 auf der
Arbeit und ich habe einen Curved Monitor.
Also das, was mir
der Arbeitgeber zur Verfügung stellt.
Der Curved Monitor ist nice,
aber mir sind trotzdem meine zwei
nebeneinander immer noch lieber.
Sagt mir tatsächlich
nichts.
Sind die auch in Frankfurt?
Guck mal, wenn es dir nichts ausmacht.
Wo sind denn die?
Ah, die sind weiter weg.
Da bin ich noch nie vorbeigelaufen.
Wir sind 60329.
Ne, komm, wir haben
schon Stalman und
Linus.
Wobei er ja ein Finne ist.
Also das ist wahrscheinlich dann eher Linus.
Weiß nicht, wie das die Finnen aussprechen.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Das ist schon fertig.
Alles fertig.
Guck hier, da ist es.
Das ist schon die neue VM.
Alles fertig.
Was wollen wir noch großartig machen?
Alles da. Ordentliches Menü.
App-Launcher,
Programm-Launcher, Fenster-Switcher,
Emoji-Picker.
Calculator schmeiße ich wieder raus.
Der ist maximal useless, habe ich festgestellt.
Wo muss ich denn hin?
Vim, Config,
Calculator.
Der ist richtig, richtig useless.
Ja.
Das müssen wir nicht mehr testen, weil
das habe ich schon.
Aber ich habe die dort falls noch nicht hochgeladen.
Das stimmt, das habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
Ja, das liegt daran,
weil der 13900K,
der hat 8 Kerne mit Hyperthreading
und
dann hat er noch mal
wie viele hat er noch mal?
12 oder so?
Efficiency-Cores, ne.
16, 16 oder?
Nochmal 16 Efficiency-Cores glaube ich.
Und dann kommst du, genau
16 und 8, genau.
Dann kommst du auf 24 Kerne,
aber nur die 8,
nur 8 davon
haben Hyperthreading und zählen quasi als logische
Cores nochmal oben drauf.
Deswegen sind es 32.
Die habe ich noch
hier auf dem anderen Rechner, weil jemand gefragt hat,
was der andere Rechner macht.
Der steht hier neben mir als Vorschau-Rechner.
Hast du nicht ein Biodynamic-Headset?
Doch.
Ich habe auch ein Mikro, aber ich bin zu faul.
Ich bin zu faul im Stream
das Mikro zu benutzen.
Das Mikro benutze ich zur, also das
das Standmikro, das größere
das benutze ich zur Aufnahme, aber im Stream habe ich
das Biodynamic-Headset auf, gut ist.
Fertig, aus.
Kann man die ISO irgendwo runterladen?
Ähm, nee,
das ist ein Skin.
Das ist ein Skin, nennt sich Mobuntu.
Das ist ein Skin für Ubuntu
1804 oder so. Ich glaube, das wird gar nicht
mehr aktualisiert. Wollen wir mal gucken,
ob das noch aktualisiert wird?
Sekunde, Sekunde, Google.
Mobuntu.
Die Seite,
die Seite sieht nach TOS aus, aber
wundert euch nicht, die Seite ist nicht TOS.
Die sieht bloß auf den ersten Blick TOS aus.
Schade, dass
der Sibaro nicht da ist.
Ja, das ist ein Skin
für Ubuntu, also wenn du ein besonders
cutes Ubuntu haben willst.
Echt? 2204?
Wie, der updatet
das immer noch? Wo steht das?
Hier, for Ubuntu. Ha!
Mit einem Easy-Install-Skript,
Leute.
Wait a minute, lass mal kurz gucken.
Gibt es das auch für Arch Linux? Nein.
Arch Linux.
Gibt's kein, Arch Linux
ist nicht cute. Was ist
das denn?
Für alle Fweeps.
Passende Gnome-Skin.
Aber wozu? Ich benutze
es doch eh nicht.
Rein für den Meme-Faktor 40
GB, na wobei, so viel braucht das ja nicht.
8G verschwenden,
dass ich es ab und zu aufmachen kann.
Aber es ist jetzt, es ist ja nicht so,
als wäre 8G jetzt sonderlich viel.
Ich mein, guckt mal, ich hab,
ich hab ja hier eine SSD mit.
Sag ich nicht.
Noch eine SSD
mit sag ich nicht.
Ah, noch 2TB, steht auch da.
2TB.
2TB und, äh,
2TB
und noch eine Platte mit,
ne, 2TB und
einen Disk. Moment, wo ist die Disk?
Und eine Disk mit, mit, äh,
8TB
glaub ich.
I don't know. Ne, 12, 12.
What? So viel hat das?
Das wären 8, 0, 12,
14, 14.
Ach, kein, das ist immer neu.
Ich weiß selbst nicht, was ich im Rechner drin hab.
Ja, also Speicherplatz ist wirklich
nicht das Problem.
Aber...
Ja, okay, weil ihr es seid.
Nächstes Mal installieren wir uns wieder
2204 und hauen Mobuntu drauf.
Die können wir dann ab und zu
mal anmachen, dann können sich alle Weebs erfreuen
und dann mach ich sie wieder aus.
Machst du im Alltag viel mit SQL?
Nö, fast gar nix. Fast gar nix.
Ich muss auch sagen, SQL
ist tatsächlich eines so meiner,
ähm,
Gebiete, wo ich
recht wenig Ahnung von
hab. Also wir haben ja im Stream
alles schon irgendwie gemacht
und ich würd auch sagen, dass ich breit mich
eigentlich auskenne, aber SQL
ist wirklich nicht meine Stärke.
Was du benutzt? Ich benutze
VMware Workstation. Ja, korrekt.
Guck da. VMware
Workstation.
Das mag ich auch nicht.
Ich, ich, ich bin auch
eindeutig der SQL
Enjoyer. Oder der SQL
Enjoyer. SQL. Wobei das
nicht nur im deutschen Bereich ist. Ich hab das
international in Videos auch schon gehört,
dass die Leute SQL sagen.
SQL Server und
sowas. Ja, VMware
Workstation hat auch keinen 144 Hertz Support.
Leider, leider.
Da bleibt wahrscheinlich nur
Linux KVM GPU
Pass-Thru. Aber im Desktopbetrieb
stört's ja nicht wirklich, ob 60 Hertz
capped ist.
Ja, das sind unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass, außerdem musst
du auch, kannst du auch
super komplexe Abfragen im Zweifelsfall
in NoSQL machen. Also
man muss das richtige Tool für den richtigen Job verwenden.
Nur weil es NoSQL Datenbanken
gibt, heißt nicht, dass man nie wieder SQL Datenbanken benutzen
muss.
Also Postgres ist auch meine Lieblingsdatenbank.
Aber ich hab von, aber ich hab
halt von SQL
selbst nix am,
nix mit am Hut.
BlendOS?
Ich bin begeistert, das hat
nen Dark Theme standardmäßig. Ansonsten
blendet das wirklich!
Die hab, sag mal, haben die vergessen?
Ist das Absicht?
Ist das Absicht, dass das
unterkringelt ist?
Oder haben die vergessen den Spellcheck abzuschalten
auf der, auf ihrem Element?
Oder ist das absichtlich
unterkringelt?
Wie prüfst du die Links? Ich hab so ein
Vorschau-Tool auf dem zweiten Rechner.
Okay.
Seriously, die haben allen ernst,
dass das absichtlich unterkringelt. Das sieht aus wie ein fehlgeschlagener
Spellcheck.
A seamless blend of all Linux Distributions.
Okay, was ist all?
Fedora und Ubuntu. Das sind
natürlich alle Arch Linux. Okay.
Aber sind trotzdem nicht alle.
Fedora, Ubuntu und Arch Linux. Das ist jetzt
weit von allen entfernt, aber es
ist ne coole,
coole Sache, aber
warum?
Also was ist der,
der Benefit, wie man da so schön sagt?
Weil die grundsätzlichen Sachen, man kann
von allen die Paketen benutzen, ist mir auch klar,
aber es gibt halt keine Pakete,
die es nicht für Arch Linux gibt und für die anderen.
Also zumindest verhält mir jetzt,
welches Paket bräuchte ich, was unbedingt
Fedora braucht,
aber es nicht für Arch Linux gibt?
SUSE Enterprise Linux, oh das ist
abfuck, ja. Okay, es hat
einen gemeinsamen Package Manager.
Ja, alles schön und gut.
Aber was ist jetzt
der große Vorteil davon?
Der Rudi Sarawat hat das
gemacht. Alter,
das ist ein 13-Jähriger.
Der hat auf seiner
Seite kein Dark Theme.
Okay, also mit 13 habe ich noch keine
Linux-Distribution selbst erstellt.
Krasser Dude.
Oder es ist Fake.
Oder, ich meine, heutzutage weiß man ja
nie. Oder es ist Fake,
dass es sich irgendwie
besser verbreitet. Man weiß ja echt
nie. Ich traue den Leuten alles zu,
heute. Ich meine, guck mal,
auch die Webseite ist mega
für einen 13-Jährigen.
Also das ist, die Webseite ist optisch,
ja, um Längen
besser als das, was ich so als Webseiten
fabriziere. Das ist
der Maintainer von Unity?
Wirklich? 13-Jähriger
ist Maintainer von Unity?
What the fuck? Alter, was
mit dem Dude los, man?
Oh, ich bin geblendet.
Sekunde. Es ist zu hell, die Seite.
Ja, stimmt.
Von wann ist die Seite? Von wann ist die Seite?
Weil damals war er 13, ja.
Okay, hier war er 12.
Der war 12 in 2022.
Das ist aktuell.
Der will es wissen, ja. Der will es
wissen. Ein 13-Jähriger.
Krass.
Pog.
Da sieht man mal wieder, wie cool
das im Open-Source-Umfeld ist.
Da kannst du es einfach machen, ja.
Und wenn es was taugt,
dann benutzen es Leute und kriegt auch ein bisschen
Aufmerksamkeit und so.
Überall anders
würden die Leute jetzt sagen,
ah, das vom 13-Jährigen erstellen,
da kann man, wer weiß, wer weiß.
Ich finde das cool.
Krasser Typ auf jeden Fall.
Weißt du zufällig, ob und wie man
einen freigegebenen Windows-Ordner
in einer Linux-VM
als Netzwerklaufwerk einbinden kann?
Ja, total einfach.
Mount.ziffs
Also du installierst,
es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten,
aber die einfachste Variante ist,
Ziffs-Mount hier
Ziff-Utils installieren
und dann sagst du
mount.ziff
Ich maunte mal schnell was,
dass du siehst, okay?
Ich maunte mal, ach nee,
Mist, Mist, ich kann nix mounten.
Die Batocera-Kiste ist glaube ich
aus.
Da kann ich nix mounten.
Also du würdest das theoretisch so machen,
hier bla bla bla, 192.168.12141
Ich glaube,
hier musst du nochmal,
nee, Moment,
das kann ich mir nicht merken,
wie Rom das stellt.
Und dann würdest du sagen
"-o guest
für den User oder
du kannst sagen username="keckel",
aber guest und username
geht natürlich nicht zusammen.
Und dann musst du
irgendwie, wohin du es mounten willst.
Und dann,
also hier, keine Ahnung, smb.
permission denied, ja logisch,
weil ich nicht root bin.
Aber selbst wenn ich root wäre,
den Server gibt's ja nicht.
Also so würdest du das machen.
Oder halt Username,
Passwort eingeben.
Schön, dass du deinen Weg hergefunden hast.
Es wird die nächsten Tage,
ich weiß nicht, was zuerst kommt,
es wird die nächsten Tage
so ungefähr 14,
13 bis 14 Minuten
Video geben
zu meiner
Emulator-Mini-PC.
Das habe ich tatsächlich mal, Leute,
stellt euch das mal vor, irgendwann werde ich noch Profi-Youtuber.
Das habe ich tatsächlich
einem Cutter geschickt, der mir das Video cuttet.
Also da gibt's demnächst
ein Video zu. Oder aber,
oder aber zuerst
Battlefield 2042, weil da kommt morgen
ein neuer Patch.
Ist ChatGPT aus? Nee.
Das müsste immer noch gehen.
ChatGPT.
Kennst du ChainLore?
Okay, ChatGPT.
ChatGPT ist
wahrscheinlich gerade wieder überlastet.
Ja, manchmal
brauchst du einfach ne Weile.
Hast du irgendwelche besonderen Einstellungen für deine
VM, die wirkt so smooth oder ist das so?
Nee, die ist so
so weich. Was ich habe ist,
ich habe keinen aufwändigen Desktop mit
Animationen und sonst was. Ich habe schlicht und ergreifend
einfach nur Fenster im Fullscreen.
Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen funktioniert
ChatGPT. Ah jetzt, okay.
Your ChatGPT session is not
usable, feelsBatman.
Okay, meine Session wurde getimeoutet.
Da müsste ich jetzt meine Credentials eingeben.
Das mache ich jetzt nicht.
Meine Session ist getimeoutet.
Eigentlich habe ich nichts.
Das einzige, was ich gemacht habe für Transparenz,
ich habe PCom laufen.
Das kannst du ausprobieren, ob dir das was
bringt. So sieht die Config dafür aus.
PCom ist übrigens auch verantwortlich
für den Blur im Hintergrund.
Ihr kennt vielleicht, dass da ein
Pepo durch
blurt.
So ein bisschen durch den Background.
So minimal.
Das ist wegen
PCom, der das macht.
Ich habe übrigens
jemand beauftragt, uns
aus diesem Pepo Hintergrund
Versionen zu machen
für morgens,
nachts,
mittags, abends.
Dann gibt es dann beispielsweise einen Pepo, wo
die Sonne scheint und Pepo, wo der Mond am Himmel
steht und wo der Pepo Zähne putzt
oder gerade was frühstückt und sowas.
Mal gucken, wann das fertig ist.
Richtig und wichtig,
genau.
Welche Tastatur nutzt du zum Arbeiten und zum Zocken?
Ah, das sind unterschiedliche Tastaturen.
Das sind unterschiedliche Tastaturen.
Und zwar, ich benutze
hier jetzt gerade
eine Logitech
G503. Mal kurz drauf
gucken. Bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Logitech
Ne, G512.
G512.
Also die benutze ich auch
zum Spiel. Meine Augen.
Meine Augen.
Die Amazon ist nicht dark moded.
So, gleich viel besser.
Also das Teil habe ich zum
Spielen und hier
zum täglichen
machen und
zum Arbeiten
habe ich
eine Ducky One
Skyline.
Allerdings Full Size
mit Numpad.
So eine hier. Exakt die da.
Habe ich zum Arbeiten.
Auf der Arbeit.
Also Eingabegeräte
habe ich ja schon eine Weile. Meine eigenen.
Also auf der Arbeit habe ich das als Tastatur.
Habe ich mir mal mitgebracht. Vor ein paar Jahren
schon. Und meine
G502 ist es glaube ich.
Was ist die
G502 dir? Also
das ist meine Ausstattung auf der Arbeit.
G502 und eine Ducky One Skyline.
Ist mir schade nicht so
geil. Geschmackssache.
Also ich finde die
zum Arbeiten angenehmer.
Weil die hat halt
tatsächlich so ein bisschen
Business Enterprise Feeling.
Durch die durch
Was zum Teufel habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Ein bisschen Enterprise Feeling
so durch die mechanischen
Tasten. Und die Tasten sind
auch ein bisschen schwergängiger als bei dem was ich
daheim habe. Ich mag
beide Tastaturen.
Keine Ahnung. Ich verwende die vorgefertigten Packages
oder installiere Sachen aus dem User Repo.
Eigene Package Build Sachen und so.
Ich meine okay.
Bei Slackware wundert mich nichts
mehr. Aber
die Arbeit mache ich mir nicht. Ich gucke manchmal
in die Build Files
rein vorher. Aber das war es dann auch.
Ja mache ich. Auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe sogar schon eine ganz lange Liste.
Neben meiner
Videothemen Liste.
Wo drinnen steht. Was ich mir schon überlegt habe.
Wobei ich sagen muss. Ganz so lange ist
jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben. Aber genug.
Also ich denke mal.
Mythen hätte ich so für
drei Videos.
Ja je nachdem.
Ein paar Sachen sind. Da sind auch so relativ
belanglose Sachen drin. Die ich wahrscheinlich nicht aufnehmen werde.
Obwohl ich nichts so aufnehmen würde.
Würde.
Ich klicke hier nichts an.
Ich klicke hier nichts vom Chainlaw an. Ohne
das ich vorher mir das angeguckt habe.
Achso.
Ist das das letzte Battlefield 2042?
Natürlich. Natürlich.
Das wird
wirklich das allerletzte jetzt.
Wird es wahrscheinlich wirklich.
Ups.
Schluck auf.
Warum kein Weep Hintergrund?
Warum sollte ich ein Weep Hintergrund rein machen?
Verwendet ihr NumPad? Ja.
Ich habe nur Tastaturen mit NumPad.
Ich brauche NumPad.
Ich mag keine
so Halbsize
Tastaturen.
Eine Razer Deathstalker.
Die Razer Namen sind
einfach immer zu. Way to dank.
Für Hardware.
Ich hatte ganz früher mal eine.
Das war damals der wirkliche
High End Maus.
Ich hatte eine Razer. War das eine Boom Slang?
Die allererste.
Ja.
Die allererste Razer Boom Slang mit dem
Maus Ball noch drin.
Review Razer
Boom Slang 2010.
Jetzt
übertreib halt mal.
Ah.
Razer Boom Slang.
Razer Boom Slang Go.
Ok.
Ja.
Wie war ich damals?
Ich glaube die erste und einzige Razer Maus mit einer Kugel drin.
Kann schon sein.
Ne. Ne. Die hieß schon Razer Boom Slang.
Relativ sicher.
Der Fanatec Headshot Controller.
Der ist auch top.
Vor allem das Kabel.
Also es geht.
Die Ducky One Skyline
mit den Tasten, die ich habe, ist nicht so laut.
Ich habe unter manchen Tasten so
Silikonringe gemacht.
So Gummiringe gemacht.
Nämlich auf die Tasten, wo ich immer besonders
feste drauf haue.
Zum Beispiel auf Numpad Enter haue ich immer mega fest drauf.
Deswegen.
Da habe ich was drunter gemacht,
dass ich die Leute nicht zu sehr nerve.
Richtig.
Genauso fühlt sich das an.
So die mechanische Tastatur auf der Arbeit.
Die hat ein bisschen schwergängigere Tasten.
Das fühlt sich so richtig
Business Enterprise mäßig an.
Also mit Enterprise meine ich jetzt nicht.
Raumschiff Enterprise.
Sondern halt so Business Enterprise mäßig.
So so.
So professionell fühlt man sich
damit irgendwie an mit mechanischer Tastatur.
Schon auf der neuen Arbeit angefangen.
Nein. Am 1.4.
Wie du die passende IP raus findest.
Äh.
Hä?
Du musst doch wissen
von welchem Rechner du was mounten willst.
Und es ist die IP von diesem Rechner.
Dort wo du auch dein
Netzwerkshare freigegeben hast.
Oder dein Samba installiert hast.
Ansonsten musst du in dein DHCP gucken,
wenn du die IP nicht weißt.
Wobei ich mich frage.
Wie hast du dein Samba darauf freigegeben,
wenn du die IP nicht weißt.
Gestern gab es. Oh nein.
Serious Marks. Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Safe. Am 1.4. kommt ein Video April April.
Ich habe doch nicht gekündigt.
Alles klar. Ja. Korrekt.
Das ist meine IP Leute. Ganz ganz genau.
Lul.
Das fängt überhaupt
noch nicht mal mit den richtigen
mit dem Vodafone
Prefix so richtig an.
Gar nicht.
Ich habe absolut gar nichts
gegen meinen Chef.
Schon mal darüber nachgedacht ein alternatives Tastatur Layout
zu lernen. Ja.
Darüber nachgedacht habe ich. Das war es dann aber auch.
Ich habe darüber nachgedacht
und habe mir gedacht. Ne.
Da habe ich keinen Bock dran mich
daran zu gewöhnen. Außerdem sehe ich
den großen Vorteil davon nicht. Und das
zweite. Sobald du mal an irgendeiner
anderen Kiste bist. Triffst du überhaupt
keine Tasten mehr.
Ist ein bisschen wie. Warum ich
weiterhin ZSH und Bash verwende.
Beziehungsweise meine Shell nicht
bis zur Unendlichkeit
vercustomise. Weil ich
täglich auf irgendwelche. Ja was ist das?
Ja doch. Täglich auf
System eingeloggt bin. Remote auf dem
ich mich sicher und
quasi aus dem Kopf raus bewegen muss.
Und wenn ich meine History überschreibe mit
FZF und sonstigen Dingern.
Dann gewöhnt man sich dran und es mag
auch besser sein als das Build in.
Aber dann kommst du mit den Remote Systemen
nicht mal richtig klar.
Mit in die Ensemble Playbooks einbauen
dass sie dir deine Shell einrichten.
Ne.
Kannst du nicht machen.
Ich kann nicht
ich kann nicht
für mich irgendwelche
Dinge auf irgendwelchen Servern installieren.
Nur weil ich gerne einen Fuzzy Finder
auf jedem Server drauf habe.
Außerdem hast du oft genug mal irgendwelche Systeme
die du nicht customised hast
vorher.
Könnt ihr 10 Finger System?
Also das klassische 10 Finger System
kann ich nicht.
Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich kann sowas ähnliches.
Was sich bei mir über die
Jahre
eingebrannt hat.
Das ist eher so ein
ab und zu mal 10 und je nachdem
wie es mir gerade ist viele Finger.
Das ist so
ja
also meistens eher so ein
6-7 Finger System oder sowas.
Ja gut das
habe ich früher gemacht tatsächlich noch auf
echten Schreibmaschinen.
Kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Wir hatten damals tatsächlich noch so eine ganz
klassische Schreibmaschine daheim.
Richtig
Also nicht die ganz billigen wo man noch
komplett selbst mit der Kraft des Fingers
das Ding aus Papier hämmern musste.
Aber sowas in der Richtung.
Und bei meinem Vater
hatten wir
eine Schreibmaschine
die hatte schon so
eine Voranzeige
was man jetzt gleich
schreiben wird.
Da konnte man dann was drin korrigieren bevor es aus Papier kommt.
Ich finde das eh cool.
Ich habe wirklich so
komplett die Entwicklung mitgekriegt.
Also ich hatte noch
so richtig so die Oldschool Kindheit
ohne großartig
viel Konsole
und ohne großartig viel Computer
und so.
Und ab
so ein bisschen angefangen
mit Konsolen
und dann ab
eher
halt dann mit dem PC.
Und dann war eh vorbei.
Also da war ich elf, zwölf so.
Dann war eh vorbei.
Dann habe ich nur noch vor dem PC gehockt.
Aber davor war ich tatsächlich
draußen und habe mit den Leuten gespielt.
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Heute spielen die
Zwölfjährigen wahrscheinlich
Fortnite zusammen.
Na gut, mit zwölf habe ich auch schon vom Rechner gehockt.
Aber die Zehnjährigen spielen heute wahrscheinlich
Fortnite zusammen. Ich war damals tatsächlich draußen.
Ich bin sogar,
muss man sich mal vorstellen,
ich bin sogar mit
Bekannten aus der Schule damals
im Sommer
auf irgendeinen Campingplatz gefahren.
Ich war bei den Pfadfindern. Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
So richtig Outdoor
Activities.
Also das kann ich mir heute
nicht mehr richtig vorstellen, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber
es war so.
Ja, Serious Max, dann den Stream
von gestern, wenn es da geleakt, wenn es da
Leaks gab, nicht ins Archiv packen.
Please.
Schon drin, ja machen wieder raus.
Falls das geht. Falls das geht.
Falls das, falls das möglich ist.
Muss ja möglich sein, da was
rauszulöschen. Ja. Was ist dein Tipp?
Ich weiß nur, dass ich
eine schnelle Reaktionszeit habe. Das haben wir das letzte Mal
ausprobiert. Ja, dann schmeiß,
dann schmeiß mal wieder raus.
Also ich weiß, meine Reaktionszeit
ist relativ schnell. Das haben wir nämlich letztens
mit irgendeinem Reaktionstest ausprobiert.
Da waren alle
extrem, äh, irritiert
dass ich schnellere
Reaktionszeiten habe wie sie mit
38. Ich meine aber
irgendwas, für irgendwas muss es gut
sein, sein halbes Leben vor dem Rechner
gesessen zu haben, oder?
Und an der Konsole.
Wie schnell war die?
Ähm, das, das schnellste, was ich hatte
war glaube ich irgendwie 155
Millisekunden und das langsamste
war irgendwas um 175 Millisekunden
oder so. Ah, das ist schon relativ schnell.
Und nachdem es live im Stream war,
wobei selbst dann hält es
nicht davon ab, die Leute sagen, ah, das war gecheatet.
Wollen wir ein Video schauen?
Das könnten wir machen. Ich weiß bloß nicht was.
Ich bin ja nur noch eine halbe Stunde
da. Ranking Linux, das
hatten wir grad schon.
Nee, nee, die Tierlist gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Der Absturz von
Netflix. Sind
Microservices überbewertet? Ja, das
beste, das passende Tool für den passenden Job.
My PC Gaming Room und Top.
Okay. So Setups gucken.
Oh nee, das ist LevelCaptchiBait.
LevelCaptchiBait.
Macht der eigentlich seine Week in Gaming
Dinger noch?
This Week in Gaming? Nee, das
gibt's gar nicht mehr, oder?
Das hat sich wahrscheinlich nicht genug gelohnt.
Okay.
Warum nicht? Warum nicht?
Sind das Lego-Figuren?
War in der Mitte des Bildschirms, was?
Ach, war in der Mitte des Bildschirms.
Hä? Was?
Ich kann dir nicht ganz folgen.
Ach, Weekly Gaming.
Ach, wirklich? Steht da nicht mal
Weekly Gaming drin?
Ja, nee, schon einen Monat her, ja.
Das da. Das macht
der anscheinend nicht mehr.
Da wird bestimmt der Helder Steine jetzt aufregen,
weil der die ganzen überteuerten Lego-Modelle hat.
Ja, Serious Max.
Lass erst mal.
What?
Der hat auch so ein Ding?
Okay, jetzt wundert mich auch, dass er in Battlefield
gar nichts mehr trifft.
Also, Felix,
Kollege von mir auf der Arbeit, der hat auch so eine komische
Maus und schwört da drauf,
ich check's überhaupt nicht,
wie man damit
arbeiten kann.
... liked and what didn't quite
measure up. Today's video is going to be a
little bit of an office tour, a little bit
of a go-buy-stuff with my Amazon
affiliate links and a little bit of looking
back at what I can say...
Ich werde übrigens demnächst, habe ich heute
klar gemacht, ich habe demnächst Geizhals
Reflinks. Wusstet ihr, dass Geizhals
eigene Reflinks hat?
War mir auch neu.
Aber ich habe demnächst Geizhals Reflinks.
Guck mal weiter.
... some of my best hardware purchases
in the past years. So, if you're building
the ultimate gaming room or the ultimate
setup, you can see what worked
and didn't work for me. Now,
first things first, I haven't done an
office tour since I moved up to
Washington State over two years
ago. This office here has been a little
interesting to work in. I put in
two large display cases for some of my
Lego... Ja, gut, das ist
nice, wenn man drauf steht. Hey!
Fractal Design F4.
Bestes, bestes Case.
Da muss ich sagen, gute
...
gute Auswahl,
weil... weil...
... PC setup into the closet
... weil ich's auch hab. ... with a big hose of
cables. This keeps my office cooler,
especially in the summer, making it
way more pleasant to game in.
Now, as for my desk setup, I used to
So, I'm kind of back...
Was hat er denn da oben für ein Gestänge am Start?
... that I could hang lights, cameras
and even mount two bigger studio speakers
from, but ultimately it became a
little redundant with some of the better
gear that's hit the market. So, I'm kind of
back to a more traditional setup, which has
made it easier to work around. So,
let's talk about the desktop and my more
recent hardware additions. All the
hardware mentioned here will be linked in
the description. If there's an Amazon
link, it'll be an affiliate link and using...
Was hat er denn da oben... Was, was hat er denn da?
Sind das, sind das
Arm... also Armauflagen
oder wie? Also sprich,
dass selbst, wenn er den Schreibtisch hochfährt,
er seine Arme auflegen kann.
... when buying gear will support
my channel. So, thank you in advance
if you do so.
Wie Frauenarzt.
Ja, ihr kommt auf Ideen, da wäre
ich nicht drauf gekommen, aber
es hat, es hat gewisse Ähnlichkeiten.
... the new main monitor
that I use for gaming and editing is
a Gigabyte M32U,
which is a 32-inch 4K
144 Hertz refresh rate
super... Ja, okay.
Monitor halt, ne?
... but on the right we have a
... even an IPS... Was denn das?
... by 2880 resolution...
Also, ein Monitor, den man hochkant
drehen kann? ... I got this because...
... turning a display sideways
even in IPS... Moment,
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist quasi ein
Monitor, zwei
Monitore in einem Case.
... sideways... Und was ist das da unten?
... even in IPS will
still often give reduced image quality
and functionality, so if you want something
built... Okay, für
Medienbearbeitung ist das wahrscheinlich
ganz cool. ... or vertical viewing, this is one of the few
options that I've found. It's kinda neat,
as you can actually have it function as either
two displays or a single
tall desktop. Now, is it
worth the price? Well, that's
for you to decide, but... Was kostet's denn? Habt ihr's gesehen?
Ich hab gar nicht drauf geachtet, was kostet's denn?
... help with
... but it can certainly be replaced with a
LISC app better, this is a great option.
... but if you want... Oh, is it
worth the price? Well, that's
for you to decide, but if you want a vertical
display to help with screen space
and reading stream chat better, this is
a great option. But it can certainly be
replaced with a less convenient and more
affordable approach of just turning a
monitor on its own. 619 Euro,
dafür geht doch ein Stück. ... das ganze Land.
... it did come with its own monitor arm though, which is
kinda cool. Now, when it comes to upgrades...
Okay, sein Rechner...
... to swap the chip... Sein Rechner sieht
rechnermäßig halt aus, ne?
So...
4090, was sonst?
Ne Maus? Das... Sag mal,
das ist eher ein Sponsored-Video, das hat
auch mit seinem Büro nichts zu tun.
Ah, oh!
Das ist nice!
Oh, now my... Da kann er
DCS spielen. Big peripheral purchases
this year were the VKB
Dual Joysticks.
Done are the days of my old... Oh, das
ist cool, das hat was!
Das ist nice!
... old Thrustmaster
Warthog Stick, though I do still
keep the throttle around as it's fantastic,
but the new era of Joysticks
are truly next level with customizable
Gimbals and Springs.
They feel incredible and they're
fully tunable to exactly what
type of game you're playing. They also
cost more than a freaking console.
Each. For games like Star
Citizen, though, they are absolute
game changers, adding a new sense of
immersion and a huge fun factor
when flying through the verse. On the right
I have the VKB Modern
Combat Grip Ultimate with a
VKB... Brrr! Ordentlicher
Preis für ein paar Joysticks. ...Gunfighter Mark 3
Base. This is arguably... Aber ich dachte
mir schon, dass die teuer sind. Als ich die das erste
Mal gesehen hab, dachte ich mir, okay, das muss teuer sein.
...one of the best Joysticks on the market
with VRPL being another
strong contender. On the left
I have the VKB Space Combat
Grip and Gunfighter Mark 3 Base
and below I have the VKB
T-Rutters. When combined...
Der kann sogar mit dem Fuß
sein Flugzeug steuern. ...and all three
of these peripherals give me unparalleled
control in Star Citizen, a game
that basically created the market
for hosauce setups. That
stands for hand on stick in
stick, as opposed to ho-toss,
which stands for hand on throttle
in stick. Alles klar. And again, say what you
will about Star Citizen, but learning
to fly in this game with dual sticks
is an experience unmatched in any
game, and I think there's a lot of other
dual stick users out there that would
back up this statement. Now the mounts for
these sticks comes from a little company called
Predator Mounts. There's all kinds of
ways to set up joysticks, and I wanted
a way that fit with my normal gaming sticks.
Da siehst du schon, was das für ein fettes Teil ist. Guck mal, wenn du
so einen Mount brauchst, dass der Joystick
ordentlich hält. ...and I wanted
a way that fit with my normal
gaming sticks, so that I could easily switch between
games without any fuss, and this
placement works out great. The mounts are
very affordable and highly customizable. Ist das ein
ehemaliger Tränkehalter? I'm a huge
fan. And of course, if you're gonna play Flight
Sims or Space Sims, an
eye tracking setup is a real game
changer. I've got the Tobii Eye Tracker
at the bottom of my screen. I can't
imagine playing Star Citizen without it. Being able
to look around the super detailed cockpits,
track targets and dogfights, and look down
when landing is absolutely key.
It would be fantastic if more
mainstream games started to incorporate
eye tracker support, like I could easily
see Battlefield being really fun
if the choppers let you look around from
first person and the jets did. It would
really just add a new sense of immersion
and ways to play the game. Now
I wish that those were some of the more expensive
Morgen kommt der neue Battlefield
Patch, dann wird eh alles besser.
...buys of this year, but I also
bought a new gaming chair. It was time
to get something new and I thought I would
treat myself this time around. I've
never owned a Herman Miller before,
so I went for the new Herman Miller embodied chair.
Fuck, der ist ja noch teurer als der
Sedos Stuhl. Naja, wobei...
...kostet ungefähr das gleiche,
wenn du rein nach dem Preis, was der
Hersteller schreibt, guckst.
...designed more for gamers, but I'll be
honest, I wasn't initially happy
with the chair. The customization and
overall design is fantastic, but the
seat was very hard and at least at
first my legs and
glutes would fall asleep when playing
for extended periods of time. I actually
got used to it now and that doesn't happen
anymore, but I really don't know what to make
of it overall. Ultimately, I do
like the chair, but I'd be more curious
about the tried and true Aeron
or one of their new Sail chairs. I've seen
similar complaints online regarding
the seat of this one as well, and it can be
really hard to judge chairs in stores
sometimes, as it just doesn't become uncommon.
It's not comfortable until you've been sitting in
this one for a long period of time. Also,
the lack of mesh backing means that
you could end up with some back sweat
if you're really locked in there.
So, fair warning, I wouldn't recommend
this chair, but I have heard good things
about the Aeron
if you want to spend some real money.
Now, I did remove the armrest
from the chair, because I still use
my old ergo rests.
I've had these desk-mounted armrests
for a long, long time. I got them to solve
the problem of chair armrests
where you would either
chafe a lot for lots of mouse
movements or mismatch armrest
height with the desk, which was
always annoying. These things are
a perfect gaming product, and in
my opinion, I can't imagine gaming
without them. Now, as for the rest
of what's on my desk, I've still
got the Audio-Technica AD700XX.
I've got the Audio-Technica AD700XX.
Now, I do save much sound by
pressing a little bit...
uh...
Kopfhörer, ich mag gute Kopfhörer, deswegen
ich hab viel, ich hab viel zu viele
davon. Und
seitdem hängt es bei mir im Regal.
Beifäder.
Ah.
Die Dinger sind richtig
nice. Ich wusste
gar nicht, dass es die noch gibt.
Die
gab es vor über 10 Jahren
schon. Vielleicht gibt es mal was Neues.
Die sind nicht schlecht.
Wofür ist denn das Digiface?
Ach,
Digital Audio Interface.
Ah, dat. Nun.
Das ist über
das Toslink-Kabel.
Und they've been highly reliable
and high quality.
They give me all the inputs I need
and allow for minimal cable running
when transferring multiple audio streams
back and forth between two PCs.
So, this is about to be the end of the video.
It's time to wrap up.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
I hope you liked it.
So, see you in the next video.
Bye!
Tschüss!
seinen Raum, weil da war
jetzt ja nicht so viel
von zu sehen.
Außer seinen Lego-Dingern.
Däner! Die gibt's auch noch!
Alter, von...
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der noch Videos macht.
Nicht, dass ich mich groß jetzt...
Ich bin ja ein großer Däner-Fan.
Aber es wundert mich. Ich dachte, der ist jetzt irgendwie Rennfahrer
und macht keine Videos mehr.
Wollen wir noch irgendwas gucken?
Das Verkehrsmittel der Zukunft. Leute, ich sag's euch.
Eure Füße.
Not clickbait.
Und...
Don't touch grass.
Noch ein kurzes Video zum Ende.
Das Weltvollkurs zum Ende.
Ja, 23 Stunden. Ich glaub, das snacken wir
kurz nochmal, das Video.
Also Alienware ist auch so ein Ding.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich war noch nie scharf drauf,
eine Alienware-Kiste zu besitzen.
Okay, 19 Things
Linux-User Never Say.
Zeig mal ja.
Das ist bestimmt Boomer-Humor.
I have nothing further to add.
Certainly not several paragraphs.
It just works.
Hey, everyone's talking about it.
Oh, dang.
No one online has encountered this issue before.
Well, when I find out the solution,
I'll definitely keep it to myself.
No, dammit, I value my time.
Okay, alles klar.
Not 0w.
Der Gaming-Linux-Guide, ja.
Wenn's sein muss.
Kobol ist eine absolute Müllsprache.
Wie...
Da hast du zwei Monate für gebraucht,
das festzustellen, oder wie?
Also ich glaube,
da war der Chat mal wieder schneller.
Der Chat wusste gleich, dass Kobol
Müll ist.
Streamer Montag, ja, aber nicht mehr lang.
Ich geh jetzt gleich pennen.
Nope.
Egal, egal,
in welchem...
in welcher Runtime Kobol am Ende läuft.
Das ist immer Müll.
Das Video kenn ich.
Ähm, das kenn ich, SiriusMax.
Da hab ich sogar drauf geantwortet.
Auf das Video.
Aber YouTube war der Meinung,
mein Comment ist Spam.
Und hat's wieder entfernt.
Ohne Scheiß, ich hab da drauf geantwortet.
Ich hab sinngemäß, glaub ich, geschrieben,
das, was ich mir dann auch auf Twitter geschrieben hab,
wenigstens verwenden die in Holland
gescheite, ne gescheite Sprache oder sowas.
Ja.
YouTube ist es egal.
Die sind der Meinung, es muss Spam gewesen sein.
Die Logik,
wann YouTube was als Spam fleckt,
hab ich eh noch nicht kapiert.
Und ich bin mir relativ sicher,
dass es selbst die ganzen krassen Google-Engineers
auch nicht wissen.
Die haben auch keinen Plan.
Ich geh jetzt ins Bett, Leute.
Wir sehen uns. Bis morgen. Macht's gut.
See you.